Hallo, guten Abend.
Wir denken, ihr habt alle ein bisschen Vorfreude mitgebracht. Wolfgang vielleicht auch. Freust du dich auf das Oktoberfest?
Nein, denn ich trinke kein Bier, versuche München zu meiden, bin froh heute in Frankfurt zu sein. Hab mich aber heute auf der Fahrt hierhin kundig gemacht, wie es bei Heidi Klungs Oktoberfest war. Und ja, die Wildecker Herzbuben sind aufgetreten und auf noch The Weather Girls.
Alle gibt's noch.
Ja, alle gibt's noch. Ich weiß aber nicht, ob sie alle vier zusammen auf einer Bühne waren.
Okay, dann feiern wir heute auch ein Fest des Lebens mit unserem Intro.
Wir können uns natürlich auch fragen, haben wir heute ein Reenactment vor? Wollen wir vielleicht einfach nochmal den Live-Salon vom vergangenen Jahr machen?
Wem ist es aufgefallen? September 24. Wer wünscht sich zurück in den September 24, als alles noch besser war? Uns der Finanzminister Christian Lindner sagte, das ist doch gerade nur eine Krise, das geht doch vorbei.
Ja, schön waren die Zeiten. Wie war es jetzt bei dir? Du hast dir gedacht, ich setze die 24 ins Cover, um an alte Zeiten zu erinnern, oder war es einfach schon die KI, die sich im Jahr vertauscht hat?
Ich weiß auch nicht. Ich habe das Datum eingeblendet. Ich weiß gar nicht. Allerdings heißt die Datei hier auch, die hat so slash Copy. Also es ist so eine, nicht die Originale, wie auch immer. Ja, aber ihr seht den Herrn Hegemon.
Auf dem Cover ist Herr Hegemon, den wir heute kennen.
Noch ist es ein Rätsel.
Gut, sollen wir uns vielleicht der Frage, ob es schon eine rechte Hegemonie gibt oder so, erstmal anders widmen? Denn es gibt ja ein sehr gutes Feature gerade beim Deutschlandfunk. Vielleicht haben es manche auch schon gehört. Insgesamt über zwei Stunden. Wir hören jetzt nur fünfeinhalb Minuten daraus. Wir werden uns also jetzt nochmal mit den Neurechten beschäftigen. Und wir hören mal rein in dieses Feature.
Deutsches Denken. Rechte Intellektuelle der Bundesrepublik. Eine Feature-Reihe von Nils Schneiderjahn und Sebastian Friedrich.
Es geht also um die Intellektuellen, um das intellektuelle Vorfeld. Und da darf natürlich der Name Armin Mohler nicht fehlen, der nach 1945 besonders wichtig wird für die Neurechten, der auch zeitweise bei Ernst Jünger ist und großer Schmidt-Anhänger ist. Und ja, das ist so die Genese, die dann auch bis hin zu Götz Kubitschek führt.
Also, aber das ist kein Vordenker von jetzt aktuell, sondern?
Also viele der aktuellen Rechten, zum Beispiel Kubitschek oder Höcke, beziehen sich auf Armin Moller. Und der hat ein Buch geschrieben, der Faschistische Stil. Und diese Reihe erzählt also erst einmal in den ersten beiden Teilen, wie das so ist, also in den 50er-, 60er-Jahren und dann 70er-, 80er-Jahren bis zur Wende. Und die anderen beiden Teilen handeln dann von der Gründung, auch der AfD und der Entwicklung jetzt. Jedenfalls geht es immer wieder auch um diese Denker aus den 60er-, 70er-Jahren, um Armin Mola. Und Kubitschek ist also jemand, der begeistert Armin Mola liest und ihn fasziniert die Lust am Streit. Und wir haben ja auch jetzt gerade immer so von den Rechten suggeriert bekommen, ja die Linken wollen ja gar nicht streiten, aber wir wollen ja eigentlich die Diskussion. Wir treten mit allen in Diskussionen und wetteln uns, wo es nur geht.
Dass Mola seinen Essay ausgerechnet den faschistischen Stil genannt hat, hält Kubitschek für etwas unglücklich. Aber...
Der Witz ist ja, dass Mola, der theoretische, hätte auch einen anderen Begriff wählen können. Also er hätte auch da schreiben, eigentlich viel besser schreiben können, der agonale Stil. Das würde mir sogar sehr viel besser passen. Also das agonale, das ist wirklich zentral. Also die reine Freude an der Auseinandersetzung.
Das klingt ja erst mal doch nach einer gewissen Sehnsucht nach Pluralität und Austausch und fast Demokratie.
Konflikt, aber wer einfach nur Konflikt mag, kann ja Meischmerger gucken oder andere. Ich habe mal eine Frage dazu. Also Armin Mola, ich habe den Namen noch nie gehört. Und ich habe jetzt festgestellt, die letzten Tage, manchmal macht es Sinn, sich kurz darüber zu verständigen, über wen wird hier gesprochen und von wem. Denn mein Verdacht war, als Charlie Kirk starb, haben sehr viele deutschen Journalisten, ah, es gibt jemanden, der hieß Charlie Kirk. Also ich habe abends den Eindruck gehabt, ich kriege Biografien runtergebetet von Menschen, die ihn gerade erst jetzt kennengelernt haben. Und das halte ich für ein großes Problem. Also Armin Mola, kennt jemand im Saal Armin Mola? Oder sollte eine Hand haben?
Das ist interessant. Also Armin Mola ist jemand, der zunächst befreundet war mit Ernst Jünger und auch quasi als Sekretär, ihm geholfen hat. Jedoch dann gemerkt hat, dass Ernst Jünger Anfang der 50er Jahre dabei ist, sein Werk, sein Frühwerk nach dem ersten Weltkrieg ein bisschen zu entschärfen, was den antidemokratischen Anklang angeht. Und Armin Mola warf Ernst Jünger also große Anpassungen vor an die bundesrepublikanische Wirklichkeit. Er sah also in diesem Vorgehen Opportunismus und darüber entzweite man sich auch. Armin Mola hat dann eine große Dissertation, das ist auch sein Hauptwerk, geschrieben. Da setzt er sich mit der konservativen Revolution der 20er Jahre auseinander, also mit jenen, die sich als konservativ und revolutionär zugleich verstehen, also die nicht mehr bewahren wollen, sondern sagen, wir müssen eigentlich das überwinden, was wir jetzt haben, vor allem den Parlamentarismus. Einige dieser konservativen Revolutionen gehen dann auch direkt zu den Nazis über, andere bleiben dazu auf Distanz. Das ist natürlich eine Riesendiskussion, wer hat da wie wem den Weg bereitet. Dieses Werk ist sehr wichtig, lesenswert und auch wirklich akademisch fundiert. Jedenfalls ist Armin Mola, der sich auch eine Zeitlang der CSU für den intellektuellen Guru im Hintergrund spielt, der sich aber dann immer, immer weiter radikalisiert, auch dann für die junge Freiheit schreibt, auch da irgendwann nicht mehr ist, weil er dann auch Fragen bezüglich des Holocaust aufwirft, wo dann auch die Chefredaktion sagt, ne, also das machen wir nicht, was Mola da vorhat. Und er, also diese immer weitere Radikalisierung jedenfalls, die hat dazu geführt, dass er auch so eine Galionsfigur der extremen Rechten bis heute ist. Und dieses Buch sagt also, was, also dieses Buch, das jetzt Kubitschek gelesen hat von Armin Mola, der faschistische Stil, das ist also jetzt so eine Aktion, dass man sagt, man stört, man geht in die Debatte, man streitet. Zum Beispiel hat Kubitschek ja auch damals eine Lesung von Günter Krass gestört. Und zugleich gibt es aber jetzt diesen Widerspruch da, dass man ja sagen könnte, das klingt ja eigentlich nach Pluralität. Und das wird ja auch gerade von Rechten in den USA immer so behauptet. Wir wollen ja nur streiten. Aber wir hören jetzt mal, wie Kubitschek und andere aus seinem Kreis das eigentlich sehen.
Geboren ist das Institut für Staatspolitik, kurz IFS. Es richtet seinen Blick bewusst auch nach Osten, wo neue rechte Strukturen auf ein politisches und zivilgesellschaftliches Vakuum treffen. Kubitschek kauft in einem Dorf in Sachsen-Anhalt ein altes Rittergut. Doch was ist das konkrete Ziel des Instituts? Was will Kubitschek politisch erreichen?
Staatspolitik, das klingt ja jetzt gerade nicht so nach Aktionismus, Störungsaktion oder so, sondern das klingt ja eher nach Staatstragendem. Kubitschek will folgenden Staat.
Was ich will, das ist einen politischen Staat. Also ein Staat, der weiß, was Politik ist, was Außenpolitik ist, wie man Handlungsspielraum bekommt, souverän ist, das eigene Volk schützt über seine Zukunft, nachdenkt, ihm eben eine selbstbestimmte Zukunft ermöglicht, sich möglichst frei macht von von so einer vassalen Rolle oder von so einer dezidiert unpolitischen Rolle, die unser Staat also nur prozentig einnimmt, weil er eben auf so eine gefühlige Art und Weise Politik macht und keine Interessenspolitik.
Das klingt jetzt sehr merkwürdig, was ist dann da der politische Staat?
Wir haben einen unpolitischen Staat.
Ja, in der Weise sieht Kubitschek das als unpolitisch, weil in diesem Staat ist das ja so, dass es mehrere Parteien gibt und der Staat an sich, sich zu diesen Parteien, solange sie auf der freiheitlich-demokratischen Grundordnung sich bewegen, neutral verhält und dann noch mal in Karlsruhe bestätigen lässt, ob das nun geht oder nicht. Aber das ist ja kein politischer Staat, so wie Kubitschek ihn versteht. Denn dieser politische Staat, der wendet sich bei Kubitschek, und wir müssen mal sagen, gleichzeitig dann bei Höcke, gegen den liberalen Staat.
Und da gehört da die Einführung illiberaler Elemente dazu. Jeder gescheite Staat hat illiberale Elemente. Der hat Elemente, über die nicht diskutiert wird.
Ah, jetzt verstehe ich es. Der politische Staat ist für jeden ein politischer Staat. Man kann also nicht einfach sagen, nee, ich will gar kein Politiker werden, ich will gar nicht zur Bundeswehr, ich will gar nicht und so weiter und so fort.
Du musst immer quasi, also Preußen ist das Vorbild für Kubitschek. Du musst dich immer als Preusse verstehen und kannst jetzt nicht einfach so dein Leben so führen, wie du das möchtest, sondern du bist ja untergeordnet dem politischen Staat.
Ja, voll logisch und voll wünschenswert.
Zugleich ist aber dann Kubitschek immer wieder beim Streit und der Provokation, aber man muss das eigentlich als den, als Mittel begreifen, um diesen politischen Staat irgendwann zu bekommen. Ich hoffe, wenn wir uns gerade in den USA das ansehen, wohin sie es gerne treiben würden, ob es dann am Ende so kommt, wird es sich zeigen. Aber ist, dass man jetzt gerade mit ganz viel Provokation arbeitet und diese ganzen Talkformate und alles da hat, wir kennen das bei YouTube, die Geschichten, dass man aber dann zugleich sagt, naja, und wenn wir dann aber Macht haben, dann wollen wir den politischen Staat und dann geht das und das nicht mehr. Dann soll natürlich nicht mehr da in Jimmy Kimmel irgendwas erzählen können in der Talkshow.
2007 veröffentlicht er das programmatische Buch Provokation, das die Strategie der kommenden Jahre beschreibt. Kubitschek will stören.
Ich meine, es gibt doch gute Filme, wo eigentlich alles in Ordnung ist und alle atmen auf. Irgendwie ist so der Burgfriede hergestellt, oder es gibt jetzt keinen Stress, keine Schlägerei, aber einer hat halt so eine Schlägerei und dann macht er halt irgendeinen Blödsinn, haut einfach einem ein Bierglas auf den Kopf und dann geht's los. Und dann ist die ganze schöne Planung im Eimer.
Und darüber freut man sich, weil das natürlich nicht den politischen Staat angreift, sondern den liberalen Staat.
Es hat nicht so den Krieg beschrieben. Alle, wie heißt der große Kriegsverdenker? Klausowitz. Alle haben einen Plan und dann beginnt der Krieg und dann hat keiner mehr einen Plan.
Ja, das ist eigentlich den Krieg nach innen geholt, weshalb so ein Traum da ist. Man findet das ja bei Ross und Topf und sonst immer wieder vom Bürgerkrieg, dass da jetzt noch mal irgendwas passiert, noch mal einmal die Messerstecherei und dann geht es aber richtig los. Dann hat nämlich einer nicht mitgespielt und dann können wir auch in die Aktion übergehen und kommen vielleicht darauf hin zum politischen Staat. Und das war natürlich auch diese Idee bei den Reichsbürgern. Weshalb man sich dann da plötzlich auch mit denen so verbundete, weil man sagt, okay, die stören ja da ordentlich, das Geschehen. Dann gibt es aber auch aus dem selben Spektrum Leute, die so sehr für den Staat sind, in grundsätzlicher Weise, dass sie etwas machen, was uns erstmal verwundert, nämlich Karl-Heinz Weissmann auch um Kubitschek herum macht Folgendes.
Auch in Schnellroder steht man nicht nur den Maßnahmen kritisch gegenüber, sondern auch den Impfungen. Anders als Karl-Heinz Weissmann, der sich Ende November 2021 für eine Impfpflicht ausspricht. Götz Kubitschek?
Das war für einen großen Teil dieses Lagers ein vollkommener Schock. Also, dass jemand wie Weissmann so etwas tut.
Sich gegen Impfungen auszusprechen?
Für.
Für die Impfpflicht, weil der Staat es ja befiehlt.
Bei der Debatte um die Impfpflicht geht es für Rechte ums Ganze, um das Verhältnis autoritärer Etatisten zum Staat.
Ich verstehe ganz genau, warum er sagt, Wir müssen auch dann gehorsam bleiben und den Staat respektieren, wenn er etwas tut, was wir für falsch halten. Also wenn jeder anfängt darüber zu diskutieren, wann er gehorsam sein, muss man nicht mehr, dann wird es schwierig. Das ist eine absolute Ausnahme, dass man nicht gehorcht.
Also, wir haben jetzt lange versucht, es zu verstehen, was da so gesagt wird. Kommen nachher auf andere Beispiele zurück. Manchmal denke ich mir, also so Politikwissenschaft, Soziologie, was Großes hilft dir gar nicht weiter, sondern wir müssen uns das kleine Ein-mal-eins der Psyche angucken und hier hat jemand einfach einen Fetisch.
Beziehungsweise der Staat ist dann gut, wenn er sich mit meinen Interessen vollkommen deckt. Also Kubitschek sagt nämlich...
Ja, aber es kann ja auch sein, dass Kubitschek sagt oder denkt, ich wünsche mir eigentlich, dass der Staat mal was befiehlt, was ich selber nicht will, damit ich den anderen zeigen kann, seht ihr und ich mache es trotzdem. Also so Dschungelcamp-Style.
Aber bei Corona hat das genau nicht getan. Da sind die Kubitscheks ja Gegner in Pflicht. Und er sagt dann Folgendes, wie er das begründet.
So und jetzt gibt es aber aus meiner Sicht eben tatsächlich eine Lage, in der wir Notfall-Libertär oder Situationlibertär sein müssen. Also weil dieser Staat Dinge tut, die man nicht mehr mittragen kann. Man kann es nicht mehr.
Also pass auf, das kann natürlich auch umgekehrt sein.
Wenn also die Leute von Kubitschek irgendwann ihren politischen Staat geformt haben, dann können wir dann wiederum sagen, ich musste leider Notfall-Libertär werden, denn das konnte ich nicht mittragen.
Warum macht man nicht sofort ein Comedy-Programm draus? The big question is, wer entzieht wem ein Visum und so weiter, because he was claimed, but no, he said, it's in the Bible, and he only quoted the Bible and only asked questions. And that is celebrated as a discourse. He went where it really hurt. And so it is here again. Okay, we are all the political state, except we are also Notfall-Libertär. Das ist wie wenn Professoren über haben wir so eine Notdissertation daraus gemacht. Wir brauchten ihn am Lehrstuhl.
Ich bin Patriot nur bei den Steuern, was dann auf. Es kommt jetzt.
Da kann ich Notfall nicht steuern zahlen.
Es kommt jetzt zur AfD.
Schwarzfahren.
Notfall-Schwarzfahren.
Also ich finde, dieses Notfall-Libertär sollte man sich für ganz viele Dinge merken, auch wenn ich mal wieder angehalten werde oder so zu schnell gefahren. Das habe ich einfach nicht akzeptieren können hier mit den 100 Innerorts.
Oh ja.
So, jetzt versuchen wir noch mal ein bisschen diese Genese der AfD. Die AfD, wir wissen, es waren eigentlich Leute, die gegen den Euro waren. Jetzt aber hat man sich ja da so entzweit. Lucke ist raus, die AfD eigentlich am Boden. Aber dann ist ja noch was anderes bald.
Tausende verlassen mit Lucke die Partei. In Umfragen stürzt sie bundesweit auf drei Prozent ab. Doch dann passiert etwas, dass der AfD-Gründer und heutige Ehrenvorsitzende Alexander Gauland später als Geschenk bezeichnen wird.
Hier ist das Erste Deutsche Fernsehen mit der Tagesschau.
Heute im Studio Susanne Daubner. Bundeskanzlerin Merkel hat die Aufnahme und Integration von Flüchtlingen zur nationalen Aufgabe erklärt.
Damit kann die AfD dann losrechen.
Das ist eben, wenn du eine politische Idee hast, die im Grunde als Lösung funktioniert, obwohl es gar kein Problem gibt. Dann betest du natürlich jeden Abend, dass es endlich dieses Problem gibt, damit du es jedem zeigen kannst. Gibt es auch aus der anderen Richtung, dass man sagt, siehst du, und jetzt geht die Welt runter. Ich habe noch mal recht gehabt. Jetzt geht wirklich die Welt runter.
Interessant ist nun, wie Erik Lehnert, das ist der Herausgeber der Secession, also der Zeitschrift, die bei Götz Kubitschek erscheint, über das spricht, was er beobachten konnte bei der sogenannten Willkommenskultur.
Wohl aber hätten die Applaudierenden an den Bahnhöfen und das ehrenamtliche Engagement Millionen Freiwilliger etwas gezeigt.
Diese volksromantischen Anwandlungen, das Volk tickt schon richtig. Man muss es nur lassen, so diese, wie hat man mal gesagt, so diese unausgesprochene oder die heimliche Mehrheit oder sowas.
Das ist Bullshit.
Also das war aus meiner Sicht eine Erkenntnis.
Das Volk, so die Erkenntnis, tickt nicht von sich aus rechts.
Bedeutet also, wie bringt man es dazu? Und das ist das wirklich Erstaunliche an diesem Feature. Ich meine, die Leute wissen ja, sie sprechen damit im Deutschlandfunk und reden da ganz frei heraus, so, noch mal Erik Lennert.
Parteien wie die AfD repräsentieren nicht einfach den Volkswillen einer schweigenden Mehrheit.
Und diese Begeisterung, Ströme, da, jo, lasst alle kommen und Merkel, wir schaffen das. Da müsste eigentlich viele von uns eines Besseren belehrt haben. Also dieses Volk ist massiv manipulierbar und wir werden es nur gewinnen, wenn wir es wieder manipulieren.
Ja, und wenn man sich das ja ansieht, wie wir gerade diese YouTube-Videos sehen, die alle nur immer in diese Richtung gehen, wir müssen eigentlich da manipulieren, da nochmal deutlich machen, hier, das ist unser allergrößtes Problem. Man kann es gar nicht fassen, dass es so ausgesprochen wird, weil geahnt haben wir es natürlich, dass es so stattfindet, aber man ist dann doch verblüfft, wenn es gesagt wird. Und du hast ja immer wieder gesagt, ja, mit dieser Anti-Migrationspolitik der AfD will man doch eigentlich ein Schrumpfungsprogramm verkaufen. Auch das sagt eigentlich Lennart.
Die AfD stellt die soziale Frage und beantwortet sie mit Nationalismus und der Ablehnung von Einwanderung. Doch geschlossene Grenzen bringen, vor allem in Verbindung mit massenhaften Abschiebungen, durchaus Probleme mit sich.
Rechte Weltanschauung hat es einfach schwerer.
Erik Lennart, Herausgeber der Secession.
Beispiel, die AfD will jetzt weniger Ausländer, wir wollen das japanische Remigrations-Migrationsmodell.
Weniger Ausländer im Land, das heißt auch weniger Arbeitskräfte.
Also einen gewissen volkswirtschaftlichen Anteil tragen die ja schon bei.
Ja, wir hatten es, glaube ich, mehrmals erwähnt in unserem Podcast. Was heißt also?
Es heißt ja für mich, ich muss den Leuten sagen, dass man oft, Freunde, also ihr werdet in Zukunft länger arbeiten müssen und weniger Urlaub machen. Das ist halt der Deal, sonst funktioniert es irgendwie nicht. Das ist ja eine Botschaft, die ist jetzt nicht jedem genehm.
Länger arbeiten, weniger Urlaub, und das müsste eigentlich auf den Wahlplakaten der AfD draufstehen. Und da kann man ja nochmal über alles diskutieren. Was er dann auch noch sagt, also ich habe ja seit vielen Jahren gehe ich ja geradezu hausieren mit dem Begriff linker Hedonismus. Ja und Eric Lennart sagt es noch einmal ganz klar, was er will und was er nicht will. Und ich fühle mich so ungeheuer bestätigt und will auch noch einmal dazu aufrufen, mir da die Treue zu halten.
Ein weitgehend homogenes Volk. Für Lennart ein zentrales Ziel, damit das Volk nicht entarte. Ein Ziel, das es aber nicht umsonst gibt.
Man kann nicht alles haben. Und ich glaube, wenn ein Rechter ehrlich ist, dann würde er das auch mal sagen. Also ich will nicht, dass du entartest. Und dass wir alle nicht entarten und dass wir nicht entartet. Heißt Zuchtordnung, Disziplin und so weiter. Und da geht es jetzt nicht um Hedo. Also Hedonismus ist nicht die Weltanschauung. Die liegt in linken Ovinea.
Richtig.
Das sollte der...
Wir genießen das Leben. Bei den anderen gibt es keinen Genuss.
Wir können dieses Leben hier nur genießen, wenn wir Strom haben. Unser Laptop ist gerade bei 6 Prozent. Ich ziehe jetzt mal die Unterstützer-Energie für den Beamer ab. Also, nicht erschrecken. Wolfgang erzählt so lange einen kleinen Joke.
Noch einen alten Witz oder so? Ich kann nicht, dass das am Ende so eine Geheimveranstaltung wird und niemand kriegt mehr die Aufnahme, weil dann alles verloren gegangen ist. Aber wir sind ja wieder ausverkauft. Das ist ja wunderbar.
Okay, also Batterie wird nicht geladen, aber Stromversorgung ist jetzt über dieses Stromkabel. Mal gucken, wir sind bei 6 Prozent. Wir balancieren jetzt.
Ich muss jetzt gar keinen Witz mehr erzählen.
Ja, erzähl ruhig zu Ende.
Okay, also der Witz ist ja der, ich hab ihn schon mal erzählt, aber ich mach's nochmal, weil er wirklich gut ist. Und zwar ist der Witz, den hat Billy Wilder mal erzählt, und zwar ist es so, dass My Fair Lady in New York aufgeführt wurde, dieses berühmte Musical, und man kam, kam nicht an Karten. Und da ist ein Ehepaar, das bemüht sich. Also und irgendwann kommen sie mal in so eine Nachmittagsvorstellung, haben endlich Karten. Und es ist alles ausverkauft. Aber neben ihnen ist ein Platz frei. Und sie wundern sich. Und in der Pause sprechen sie dann den Mann neben sich an und sagen sie Entschuldigen Sie, wie kann das sein, dass der Platz ist neben ihnen frei? Das ist ja eine tolle Reihe, wo wir sitzen. Was ist da los? Und der Herr sagt, ja, es ist leider sehr traurig. Der hätte normalerweise meine Frau gesessen, aber die ist verstorben. Und ja, das ist natürlich alles schwierig. Und dann sagt der andere, ja, aber gab es da nicht irgendwie eine Möglichkeit, das Ticket zu verschenken an einen Bruder, einen Schwager, einen guten Freund oder eine Schwester? Dann sagt der Ehren, das ist das Problem. Die sind alle auf der Behandigung.
Man muss Prioritäten haben und linker Hedonist sein. Okay, sehr gut. Ich kann, glaube ich, der Computer lädt so ein bisschen entspannt jetzt hier Herrn Hegemon besprechen. Herr Hegemon, wir kennen ihn auch, weil Wolfgang immer wieder Angst hat vor dem Hegemonialen.
Und das kommt auf an, wer es füllt, das Hegemonialen.
Genau. Ist ja die Frage, wie können wir uns das vorstellen? Also, der Herr Hegemon spielt eine ganz kleine Rolle, wenn man so wie hier in einen Raum kommt und weiß, hier ist alles so eine Wellenlänge, alle verstehen sich gut, vielleicht kennt der eine den anderen, die Stimmung ist grundsätzlich gut. Hegemon ist eher so der Feind, wenn man in einen Raum kommt, wo man niemanden kennt und dann feststellt, hier mag ein auch keiner. Also hier hat man auf jeden Fall mit jedem Wortbeitrag, den man abgibt, muss immer so eine gewisse Rechtfertigungspflicht mitlaufen. Man muss immer erklären, warum man jetzt aufsteht, wie auch immer. Ich habe das schon mal an diesem Spruch verdeutlicht, wenn man bei einer Abendveranstaltung, du machst ja auch häufig welche, hinten jemand aufsteht und bevor er etwas sagt, erstmal fragt, darf ich auch als alter weißer Mann was sagen? Dann weiß man, er sieht gerade den Hegemon nicht auf seiner Seite, sondern er hat gerade Probleme.
Ich habe mich zuletzt so gefühlt, als ich beim Bayerischen Landesverband für Groß- und Außenhandel war. Da merkte ich, dass der Hegemon nicht auf meiner Seite war. Neben mir saß Professor Bausbach von der CSU, der ein bisschen verwundert war über mich.
Der hatte den Hegemon, das ist wahrscheinlich Herr Hegemon selbst.
Der war sogar so stark, dass er sagte, ja, es lüft sich gut an mit der Regierung jetzt in Berlin. Das liegt natürlich auch in unserem schönen Einfluss, den wir von der CSU nach Berlin haben.
Die Leute wissen immer Bescheid. Alles ein Selbstläufer. Man ist halt auf der richtigen Seite. Und das neokalvinistische Prinzip, mir geht's gut, ich gehöre zu den Guten. Ich muss doch hier nichts erklären. Natürlich möchte ich entweder mit dem Flugzeug in die Oper nach Palermo oder einen hohen SUV, weil mir die Knie wehtun beim Einsteigen und ich mich zu weit falten muss. Wie auch immer. Um mal Elke Heidenreich und Jörg Tadeusz aufzugreifen. So, und wir wollen uns jetzt diesem Herrn Hegemann annähern. Und können aber nicht weiter an die Erklärung ranrücken, als das, was ich jetzt gesagt habe gerade. Weshalb wir weitere Grundbegriffe brauchen. Wir nehmen uns also zwei Textgrundlagen, was ja jetzt häufiger gut funktioniert, weil wir mit 11 Labs tolle Stimmen haben, die aus Büchern alles rausholen. Mein Buch Redaktionsschluss von vor zehn Jahren ist natürlich schon sehr klug. Also da muss relativ wenig rausgeholt werden. Ich habe es trotzdem vorlesen lassen. Es geht um den Unbekannten. Jetzt geht es einfach darum, wer ist hier gemeint, was ist der Unbekannte. Danach hören wir den noch, den Debilen und den Dummen. Also es geht um den Unbekannten, den Dummen und den Debilen. Auskennende wissen schon, was wir als nächstes hören. Aber jetzt hören wir erst einmal Redaktionsschluss. Und zwar das allerletzte Kapitel. Das ist eine halbe Seite. Also wir hören die Überschrift dann sozusagen Ausklang aus dem Buch.
Kommunikation unter Unbekannten. Wie also? Das war die Ausgangsfrage. Können wir uns über die Welt, in der wir leben, noch verbindlich verständigen? Geben dir doch einfach zu, dass wir es nicht wissen. Wir können nur hilflos einen letzten historischen Bogen schlagen, um das Nachdenken noch einmal zu befördern. Wir leben heute nicht in archaischen Anwesenheitsgesellschaften. Zumindest das verstehen wir. Wer in einen Zug steigt und hinter dem Horizont verschwindet, bleibt immer noch in der Welt. Die Medien, vom beschriebenen Papier bis zum live übertragenden Fernseher, haben uns mit einer Adresse versehen. Wir wurden überall erreichbar. Nun, im Zeitalter des allgegenwärtigen Netzes sind wir selbst zu ununterbrochen funkenden Sendern geworden. In der reichhaltigen, vielfältigen und alltäglichen Kommunikation, in der wir uns verfangen haben, geriet ausgerechnet derjenige aus unserem Blick, mit dem wir uns am dringlichsten über die Welt verständigen müssen, mit dem Unbekannten, von dem wir nicht mehr wissen, in welcher Welt er lebt, weil es in unserer Zeitung nicht mehr steht.
Also das alte Bild, warum liest jemand Zeitung? Nicht um zu hören, was in der Welt los ist, sondern um zu sehen, was andere sehen, wenn sie sich fragen, was ist in der Welt los? Wir haben da so ein bisschen Silicon Valley mit diesem mimetischen Begehren und so. Man begehrt nicht irgendwelche Sachen, sondern man guckt erst mal, was die anderen so begehren. Dann orientiert man sich, dann hat man so ein soziales Alignment und so weiter und so fort. Wir haben ja bei Rutger Brechmann die ganze Intelligenz kommt aus dieser sozialen Koordination. Und in der fehlt nun mal der Unbekannte, also 80 Millionen Deutsche und wir sehen so die Tagesschau und wir fragen uns, für wen wird die Dattelart gemacht? Wer sind diese anderen alle? Mit ihnen in Kontakt treten und irgendwas ausdiskutieren, das schaffen wir nicht, sondern grundsätzlich einen Unbekannten. Und jetzt ist die Frage, wenn wir so eine Maischberger Sendung sehen, da finden ja durchaus doch Diskussionen statt. Nur halt nicht von allen 80 Millionen Deutschen, sondern da wird irgendwie der Unbekannte immer so reingeholt, der läuft immer so mit. Und jetzt hat man zwei Möglichkeiten. Wir hören jetzt also den Beginn von Slavoj Zizek, weniger als nichts, da spielt dieser große andere eine Rolle. Aufgeschlüsselt in den Dummen und den Debilen bei der Frage, wie orientiere ich mich jetzt sozial in einer Lage, in der es ganz wenig Anhaltspunkte für Orientierung gibt.
Und du hast es jetzt von so einer Shijek-Stimme vorlesen, Rache?
Nein, ich mache den Witz auch nachher noch mal, den du jetzt schon gemacht hast, weil wir haben ja das letzte Mal Jens Jessen gehört, wie wahrscheinlich Jens Jessen in seinem Kopf klingt, wenn er seinen Text schreibt. Und wir hören aber gleich den echten Jens Jessen. Freut euch schon mal. Aber erstmal, wenn man Slavoj Žižek ist, was die Tonalität ankommt, nicht wiederzuerkennen.
Es gibt zwei entgegengesetzte Arten von Dummheit. Die erste liegt vor, wenn ein gelegentlich hyperintelligentes Subjekt es einfach nicht kapiert, wenn es also eine Situation zwar logisch begreift, aber deren versteckte kontextuelle Regeln nicht erfasst. Als ich beispielsweise zum ersten Mal in New York war, fragte mich der Kellner in einem Café, wie war ihr Tag? Ich antwortete wahrheitsgemäß, ich bin totmüde, habe ein Jetlag, bin völlig gestresst. Und er schaute mich an, als wäre ich ein Vollidiot. Und er hatte Recht. Diese Art von Dummheit ist exakt die eines Idioten. Im Bereich der Literatur fällt einem hier unweigerlich, Jaroslaw Hajek's braver Soldat Schweig ein, der, als er sieht, wie Soldaten aus dem Schützengraben ihre Feinde beschießen, zwischen die Fronten läuft und losschreit, Hört auf zu schießen, da sind Menschen auf der anderen Seite. Der Prototyp dieser Art von Dummheit ist freilich das naive Kind aus Andersensmärchen, das öffentlich ausruft, dass der Kaiser nackt ist. Und dabei offensichtlich nicht begriffen hat, dass, wie Alphonse Allais es formuliert hat, wir unter unserer Kleidung alle nackt sind. Die zweite, entgegengesetzte Art von Dummheit wollen wir hier als Debilität bezeichnen. Debil ist demnach jemand, der sich vollkommen mit dem gesunden Menschenverstand identifiziert und ganz für den großen anderen des äußeren Scheins steht.
So, also wir haben den Unbekannten, der sich jetzt fragt, warte mal, was ist das für ein Raum, was sind das für Leute, woran orientiere ich mich jetzt? Der Dumme bleibt ganz bei sich und alle anderen so, ey du bist echt dumm und selbst schieselig sagt, ich war selber dumm, als ich das so gemacht habe. Oder der Debile, der sich einfach völlig hingebt zu einem Vibe, aber er muss sich halt irgendwas ausdenken, so. Und jetzt hören wir Jens Jessen. Wir müssen dabei mitlaufen lassen, die Frage ist er dumm oder debil? Also sozusagen entschuldigt, da kommt gar nicht raus aus dieser Falle, wenn man jetzt für eine Falle gestellt. Jens Jessen war...
Also debil müssen wir vielleicht doch noch mal charakterisieren. Also mit debil meint Cizek eigentlich dieses sich wohlfühlen im gesunden Menschenverstand. Also Cizek ist ja der Denker des Kontra-Intuitiven. Also der eigentlich immer diese Frage stellt, die beginnt mit was aber wenn, wenn es also doch anders ist. Und derjenige, der sich diese Frage nie stellt, sondern einfach so sagt, ja, so ist die Welt, so ist gesunder Menschenverstand, der wäre dann als der Debile zu bezeichnen.
Das haben wir doch schon immer so gemacht. Wir wollen uns doch jetzt nicht hier überraschen. Wir machen es, wie wir es fühlen. Das weiß doch jeder. So jetzt Jens Jessen. Jens Jessen war die Tage gestern, vorgestern irgendwann im SWR Kulturforum, heißt es jetzt, früher SWR 2 Forum, zusammen mit Nils Kumka. Dann hatten wir schon mal so eine schöne Clip-Grundlage, dass wir den einen Text lesen und ganz blöd finden und den anderen Text zumindest ich super cool finde.
Ich fand ihn ja auch nicht schlecht. Das will ich ja nochmal betonen. Ich hatte nur Kritikpunkte. Du hast ja eine Heilig-Sprechung vorgenommen.
Ja, genau. Also Nils Kumka hat durchaus Heilig. Und die beiden sind in einem Radio-Gespräch aufeinander getroffen. Was für eine schöne Fügung. Ich habe das sehr gerne gehört. Empfehle es ihr also auch in voller Länge. Jetzt bleiben wir aber bei unserer Fragestellung. Also Jens Jessen soll jetzt mal erklären, diese linken Diskurswächter, über die er da in seinem Text geschrieben hat, wer sind die eigentlich? Und jetzt eben bitte antworten sie spontan. Also kann durchaus gestammelt werden. Bitte antworten sie in ihrer eigenen Stimme. Ich will mich nicht lustig machen, aber es ist schon überraschend, wie es dann klingt, wenn solche Leute, die einen Vöter-Aufmacher schreiben, oder einen Zeitaufmacher, 600.000 Auflage und so, wie die dann plötzlich im Radio ins Schwimmen kommen, wenn sie gefragt werden, können wir mal ganz kurz, ich habe eine Frage zu ihrem Text.
Herr Jessen, Sie sprechen ja von linken Diskurswächtern in Ihrem Text. Wen haben Sie denn vor Augen, wenn Sie von der Linken sprechen?
Und was ist das, was Sie an diesen Leuten auf die Palme bringt?
Also zunächst mal habe ich das nicht konstruiert, sondern ich gebe eine Wahrnehmung wieder. Nun können Sie sagen, die lässt sich empirisch nicht untermauern, Herr Kupka, aber ich denke, sie ist doch vorhanden und das ist kein Phantasma. Also das fände ich jetzt ungewöhnlich träge und denkfaule Meinung, dass man alles, was sich nicht wirklich erhärten lässt, auch nicht in den Köpfen der Leute rumspuckt.
Dabei sagt ja eigentlich Kupka anfangs in seinem Buch, er kritisiert ja Kollegen von Triggerpunkten, dass sie immer so sagen, es gibt keine Spaltung, sondern sagt aber doch Kupka, naja, also man kann das jetzt empirisch erstmal so alles zusammentragen, dann sagen, es gibt keine Spaltung, aber es gibt sie eigentlich schon doch und darauf setzt er die Argumentation dann an. Kommt dann dann noch mehr?
Ja, wir folgen dem jetzt gleich noch ein bisschen. Ich fand noch mal, also er wird so befragt, naja, es ist auf jeden Fall kein Hirngespinst, sagt er, sondern es folgt so einem Gefühl. Er weiß nicht genau, wo er es verorten soll, also wo der Unbekannte steht und wie das so zu, aber er fühlt da was und das ist ja eigentlich die per se Definition des debilen Nachdenkens über solche Sachen. Ich mache mich nicht klug, ich frage hier auch nicht nach, sondern ich komme in einen Raum und habe halt so ein Gefühl und sage dann einfach, ja so ist es doch.
Ja, das war ja eigentlich vergleichbar mit dem, was wir gesehen haben bei Thomas Gottschalk, der nicht fähig war bei seiner Kritik der political correctness und ich finde, es gibt Punkte, wo man auch Kritik üben kann, aber er nicht in der Lage war, sie zu präzisieren und dann sagte, ja es gibt ja immer Leute, dann sagt mal Königsberger Klopse und irgendjemand regt sich auf, dass es Königsberg ist oder so. Da denke ich mir, ja, aber wer soll das sein? Also das sind die Hirngespinste, aber kann natürlich sein, dass man die dann eher im Bauch beim Gefühl verortet.
Genau, also weit über, das sind Hirngespinste, sind wir jetzt bei Jens Jessen im ersten Anlauf nicht hinausgekommen. Jetzt wird er so gefragt, aber diese Milieus, die sie da beschreiben, die sind auch total plural. Warum machen sie da jetzt so, und das ist uns ja auch aufgefallen im Text, es beginnt so mit so einer Unterstellung, das sind die ehemals Regierenden und ne, Olaf Scholz kann er wohl nicht gemeint haben und am Ende sind es nur noch so die Straßenkleber oder so, die alle so in ein kollektives Milieu reingesteckt werden.
Und natürlich kann man sagen, ja, das sind alles unterschiedliche Gruppen, die ihre unterschiedliche Agenda haben.
Also sieht er durchaus, mal gucken, wie er das jetzt auflöst, da so eine Gemeinsamkeit herzustellen.
Aber tatsächlich sind sie doch, also da würde man sich, was in die Tasche, sind sie miteinander verwandt und stützen sich gegenseitig. Sonst wäre es ja, es wäre ja zum Beispiel sehr klug gewesen, wenn die Grünen oder der Linkspartei oder wo auch immer Politiker sagen würden, das ist nicht unsere Agenda, das wollen wir nicht. Wir wollen kein Gedicht von Gomringer verbieten oder solche Sachen. Aber das ist in der Tat nicht geschehen. Und wenn sie sich Parteiprogramme der Grünen angucken, dann gibt es dort auch Passagen, die eben sich gegenüber diesen Milieus verbeugen.
Zu wenig Bekenntnisse wurden abgelegt. Jeder, der kein Bekenntnis ablegt, ist in diesem Milieu.
Also heißt, die müssen sich jetzt laufend einnischen in so Irrsinnstippen.
Ja, also wenn du ein Klimakleber bist, musst du erstmal erklären, bevor du sagst, dass du was gegen die CDU und CSU-Verkehrspolitik hast, wie du zu den Linken stehst, den Grünen, Tierschutzpartei, beziehungsweise die Parteien der Organisation.
Also natürlich kann ich jetzt sagen, es gibt Verwandtschaften. Aber ich glaube, das funktioniert nur für eine Vögeltonseite dann.
Ja, hat er ja auch gedacht, bis er eingeladen wurde im Radio. Und jetzt wird er vorgeführt, der arme Mann. Der arme, alte, weiße Mann. Okay, er hat noch ein anderes Merkmal, das er gerne sehen würde, um dann zu sagen, seht ihr doch keine linken Diskurswächter im Allgemeinen und miljöübergreifend, sondern was auch immer, wie er sich das dann vorstellt. Also zu wenig Anti-Vogel-Bekennnisse worden abgelegt und...
Also wenn man den Eindruck hätte, es würde da viel mehr gestritten und gezankt jetzt im weitesten Sinne in dem in linken politischen Zusammenhängen, dann würde die meiner Meinung nach die Lage schon ganz anders und viel besser aussehen.
Aber das ist doch das Gegenteil eigentlich. Also das Klischee von linken ist, treffen sich drei Linke, hat man fünf Meinungen und zwei Parteien werden gegründet. Also das ist ja doch eher selten, dass man sich einig wird. Und das beginnt ja dann schon bei Sprachreglungen. Und da sind wir noch gar nicht bei den großen geopolitischen Fragen angelangt. Das hatte ich jetzt für eine sehr eigenartige Auffassung da. Also ich glaube, er beschreibt immer ein bestimmtes Milieu, in dem sich das alles so deckt. Aber ich würde immer wieder betonen, das ist so ein Milieu, das tatsächlich sehr überschaubar ist, aber mit der Wirklichkeit dann wenig zu tun hat. Also das ist immer nur auf Berlin gedacht oder so. Und da aber auch nur für Berlin Mitte und die paar Medienleute, die man kennt.
Jetzt hörst du dich schon fast an wie Nils Kumka. Wir überprüfen das gleich. Ja, also wir sind jetzt so weit fortgeschritten, dass Jens Jessen uns einen Text erklärt mit zu wenig Antivogenbekenntnisse im Antivogenlager. Dadurch so ein Milieuübergreifendes, keine Ahnung, dagegen muss man sich ja wenden. Es wäre doch schön gewesen, wenn sie noch mehr gezankt hätten. Jetzt wollen wir das so ein bisschen auf diese Sozialdimension von der Sachdimension. Also worüber könnte man so zanken? Wer zankt? Jens Jessen ist jetzt bereit, mal ein paar Namen zu nennen von Institutionen, die er auf jeden Fall völlig abgedriftet. Und wie wir jetzt wissen, zu wenig im Zank und mit zu wenig Bekenntnissen sehen.
Ich meine, es gibt ja gar keinen positiven Grund, die AfD zu wählen. Sie hat um gar Wahrheit gar nichts anzubieten außer ihrem Hass.
Und damit leitet er ein. Und warum wird sie trotzdem gewählt? Also wer ist denn jetzt hier da an Schuld? Das kann ja wohl nicht die AfD selber sein. Die macht ja gar kein Angebot, was ich auch eine sehr clevere Argumentation finde.
Sie holt die Leute nur bei ressentimenten und negativen Empfindungen ab. Und deswegen ist es eben zumindest unklug, eben solche Ressenten mit offener Bluse umzulaufen und zu kurzem Rock, also so da sind wir jetzt. Die Maus zu schüren oder nicht wenigstens zu sagen, ja das geht uns auch zu weit, das finden wir jetzt nicht richtig und so weiter und so fort. Und es bleibt ja auch nicht völlig in der Welt, die Welt, die Medien spielt sicher eine große Rolle, das ist klar. Also wenn ich zum Beispiel morgens den Deutschlandfunk, eigentlich seit Jahrzehnten meinen Stammensender einschalte, dann werde ich bis abends agitiert. Das ist schon wahr. Aber nun muss man ja den Deutschlandfunk nicht mehr einschalten. Aber eben es geht eben auch in die Wirklichkeit.
Der Deutschlandfunk? Ist für ihn ein Agitationsmedium?
Ja, also ich hätte jetzt wirklich gedacht, dass er jetzt die Tatz nennt und Luisa Neubauer und Greta Thunberg und weiß ich nicht wen, aber gut, da wäre ich jetzt nicht drauf gekommen. Also ja, da gibt es natürlich auch Berichte, die sich mit den Themen, die jetzt Jessen identifiziert in seinem Artikel auseinandersetzen. Und da kann auch eine gewisse Tonalität angeschlagen werden, mit der man nicht einverstanden ist. Nur, dass das jetzt so rund um die Uhr passiert.
Ja, unser Laptop ist jetzt bei zwei Prozent angekommen. Das ist ja ein bisschen dramatisch hier, muss ich ehrlich sagen.
Vielleicht sollten wir irgendwas tun vorher, bevor wir das jetzt bei so ein paar Clips hatten wir ja schon noch gedacht. Das wäre heute der kürzeste Salon aller Zeiten sonst. Das wollen wir nicht.
Ähm, Ups, macht euch keine Sorgen, der Podcast wird hier aufgezeichnet. Nur, Clips wollten wir eigentlich schon noch spielen. Ich starte einfach mal neu. So, Wolfgang erzählt jetzt noch zehn Witze.
Ich habe eine unglaublich anstrengende Woche hinter mir. Habe auch so eine gewisse Bandbreite des bundesöpublikanischen Diskurses mitbekommen. Ich habe diese Woche gesprochen mit Michel Friedmann. Und die Macht der Bilder. Mit Natascha Strobl über autoritäre Führer. Und war bei Ben Ungescripted. Wo ich linke Positionen unterbringen wollte, merkte aber dann, wir müssen mindestens eine Stunde über Messerstecher reden. Und hinzu kam noch, dass ich, als ich dort ankam, zu Ben Ungescripted vor mir schon jemand da war. Und hatte gerade das Interview dort geführt. Und es war Olli Pocher. Und ich habe mich gefragt, wo bist du hier eigentlich? Insofern ganz schön heute hier zu sein. Jetzt sind wir wieder unter uns. Nein, mit Friedmann und Strobl war es natürlich sehr angenehm. Ja, wir werden sehen, das Gespräch mit Friedmann ist auch aufgezeichnet. Also mit noch zwei weiteren Gästen dann auf dem Podium. Das kommt irgendwann bei YouTube. Und das Gespräch mit Ben ungeskriptet wird dann auch in drei, vier Wochen erscheinen. Und ich kann auch noch ein bisschen Werbung machen, denn morgen will jemand noch in Frankfurt sein sollte. Die Frankfurter Rundschau, die feiert Geburtstag und hat da ein großes Fest am Haus am Dom. Und da sind ganz viele verschiedene Veranstaltungen. And then I will also tomorrow at 11 p.m. and discuss about democracy. So we stay on the topic. Moment. So it seems to be building up again. Heidi Klum is also still with Jürgen Dreeves. Sie ist wieder aufgetreten, zurückgekehrt aus dem Ruhestand. Wie alt ist er denn? Noch mal ein Wett im Kornfeld, 80. Roberto Blanco, 88. Hatte ein bisschen Spaß muss sein gesungen. War mit seiner bezaubernden Frau Lussandra dort. Marianne und Michael haben in München steht ein Hofbräuhaus gesungen.
Das ist ein Hofbräuhaus.
Ich liebe es.
Aber ich hab es mir nicht angeguckt. Ich hab alles heute nur im Schnellverfahren recherchiert. Hat es jemand geguckt, der ist dann bei ProSieben? Nein. Das ist auch ein gutes Zeichen für unser Publikum, dass keiner Bescheid weiß.
So, ich stecke jetzt mal den Beamer wieder rein.
Als ich gestern in Bord, bis Drosas im ICE, da ist ja wirklich noch ganz alte Bundesrepublik. Also es sind ja dann viele, die auch, also viele Herrschaften schon in der Rente, die dann auch ab 11 Uhr zum Wein greifen. Und ich saß wirklich drei Minuten da und zwei Damen unterhielten sich schon über Masuren. Und das war, klang aber schon so ein bisschen nach Marion Gräf in Dönhof und so. Also das war noch, man hätte auch glauben können, dass gleich Helmut Schmitzig noch dazusetzt und eine Zigarette raucht. Es ist wirklich faszinierend. Bord bis Droh und der Bahn. Das ist die Welt, die die CDU aufrechterhalten möchte, aber die einfach nur noch dort ist.
Völlig zurecht, würde ich sagen.
Es ist irgendwie auch schön. Es hat auch so was unaufgeregtes.
War vorher jemand, es war jemand mit bei Mary's Stadtführung. Sie hat uns ja ganz kurz die Kleinmarkthalle gezeigt mit dem Verweis auf. Und da sitzen morgen wieder die Leute und trinken bis 16 Uhr Wein ab, keine Ahnung, 19 Uhr oder so. Und dann war zuerst, es waren ja laute Leute aus Nicht-Frankfurt da, die dachten, das ist für die alten Leute. Aber nein. Also ich bin morgen nicht dort, aber ich war letzte Woche da. Das ist schön.
Date-Trinking, wenn die jungen Leute das.
So, ich habe das Problem gefunden. Ich möchte das kurz schildern. Die Clips von Jens Jessen waren dem Computer zu blöd. Deshalb wir jetzt umschwenken auf die Clips von Nils Kumpka. Wie wir Neue wissen, einer der klügsten Soziologen und Menschen, die wir haben. Denn die Punkte gehen wirklich ins Mark. Wir hören zwei Ausschnitte.
Da lohnt es sich vielleicht auch wirklich mal über die Schwäche der Linken einfach aktuell zu reden, ist in der Tat eine gesellschaftliche Erschöpfung von Zukunftsvorstellungen. Also wenn ich die Artikulation von Gruppeninteressen immer nur als Beschneidung meiner Gruppeninteressen wahrnehmen kann, also wenn Frauen ihre Rechte einfordern, das automatisch bedeutet, dass ich als Mann indoktriniert, beschnitten und klein gehalten werde, dann deutet das ja darauf hin, dass wir uns nicht mehr vorstellen können oder dass viele Menschen sich nicht mehr vorstellen können, dass wir unter Umständen auch gemeinsam mehr haben könnten. Also diese Krise des Gemeinsamen ist glaube ich nicht nur ein Attribut der Identitätspolitik, sondern die Krise des Gemeinsamen, die beobachten wir in der Tat in der Soziologie jetzt schon seit 20, 30 Jahren insgesamt gesellschaftlich. Diese Vorstellung, dass wir überhaupt noch gemeinsam was auf die Reihe kriegen, die nimmt bei vielen Leuten immer mehr ab. Und vor dem Hintergrund wirkt Identitätspolitik dann ja auch erst so bedrohlich.
So, sehr klug Punkt. Ich habe häufiger schon darauf hingewiesen. Wenn man in einen Raum hineinkommt und man weiß, da wird grad nicht gemeinsam aufgebaut, sondern ab jetzt beginnt eine Diskussion, bei der jeder Gewinn von mir ein Verlust für jemand anderen ist, dann wird natürlich ganz anders diskutiert. Dann stehen hinten die Leute auf, entschuldigen sich dafür, dass sie auch als Männer noch mal was sagen dürfen vielleicht und so. Weil jede eigene Ergreifung eines Rechts ist dann gleichzeitig jemand anderes wird in seinem Recht beschnitten. Und nur wenn uns Zukunft fehlt und sei es als Phantasma, kommen wir überhaupt in diesen Modus. Ansonsten könnte es ja einfach jedem total scheißegal sein, was der andere macht. Aber da überall die Bedrohung lauert, oh nee, jetzt trinken die schon wieder Hafermilch. Mal gucken, wie lange ich noch meine Kuhmilch trinken darf und so. Dann wird es natürlich brenzlig. Also in der Hinsicht, das ist einer der wichtigsten Punkte überhaupt. Ab jetzt wird alles ökonomisch verrechnet. Und wir wissen ja, kleine Gasrechnung ein bisschen höher ist schon, alles kurz vor dem Bürgerkrieg. Aber wenn man so unbestimmte Verkalkulierungen in allen Feldern plötzlich hat und jeder Kulturkampf, also jedes harmlose Kulturkampfthema plötzlich in so eine Rechnung reingeht, wo man immer so ein Minus fürchten muss für sich, dann wird es natürlich heikeln. Also in der Hinsicht ein sehr guter Punkt. Zweitens, und jetzt greift er Jens Jessen direkt auf. Du hast es eben auch schon beschrieben. Wo findet man denn diese Milieu, dass da so Jens Jessen als Phantasma vorschwebt? Und ich finde, Kumpka beschreibt es einfach wunderbar.
Wir müssen aufpassen, dass wir nicht dieses kommunikative Ordnungsmuster der Polarisierung für den politischen Konflikt selber nehmen. Sondern es ist eine ganz, ganz spezifische Form, diese politischen Konflikte zu führen, die dazu führt, dass diese Schemata immer wieder plausibel scheinen. Und wenn wir dann im Föeton oder im Kulturradio mal die Chance haben, darüber zu reden, dann liegt, glaube ich, eine wichtige Aufgabe von uns, einfach darin, genau diese Wahrnehmung erst mal zu problematisieren. Nicht um zu sagen, dass sie eingebildet ist. Die Leute sind ja nicht verrückt, sondern um die komplexen Mechanismen zusammen aufzudröseln, die dazu führen, dass manchmal wahnsinnig disparate, wie zum Beispiel das unmittelbare soziale Nahumfeld von Journalistinnen in Berlin plus Medienstrategien der Rechten plus massenmediale Konfliktinstallierung, dazu führt, dass wir alle das Gefühl haben, in einer polarisierten Gesellschaft zu leben, obwohl wir als Sozialwissenschaftlerinnen, wenn wir versuchen, das zu messen, und das wird ja einigermaßen verzweifelt und seit mehreren Dekaden versucht, genau diese Polarisierung regelmäßig nicht finden.
Ja, also so wie man einen Kreis um Indonesien, China und Indien machen kann und sagen kann, guck mal, auf diesem kleinen Feld, das macht gerade mal vier Prozent der Fläche aus, lebt jeder, so grob überschlagen, könnte man hier einfach sagen, okay, wir nehmen jetzt Berlin. Da, wo die AfD Parteizentrale ist, da, wo die Maischberger-Sendung geplant wird, Schiffre natürlich, für alles möglich, was die AfD macht. Und da haben wir die Naharbeitserfahrung von Jens Jessen. Also Jens Jessen sieht ein Milieu bei sich, so wie der NDR auch 250 Leute unterschreiben, dass die Frau, die einen Stock höher arbeitet, bitte nicht da arbeiten soll. Plötzlich ist ganz Deutschland davon sehr bescheuert. Also wir haben eine Nahe-Erfahrung von Jens Jessen, die wird dann katalysiert durch rechte Medienstrategien. Also die AfD weiß genau, wir haben hier gar nichts auf der Pfanne, wir müssen einen Kulturkampf machen. Aufmerksamkeit ist King, da wird es geupgraded auf Aufreger-Themen und dann ist sozusagen dieser Beitrag schon gegeben. Und dann kommen die massenmediale Konfliktsensurik, die einfach sagt, ja, also darüber sollten wir mal reden, ganz Deutschland redet darüber. Und dann wird händeringend ein Gegenpol gesucht und dann muss man sich entscheiden zwischen laden wir nochmal Jan Fleischhauer ein oder heute doch Ulf Poschart und das war's schon so ungefähr. Das wird aber dann medial dargeboten als das ist es. Also hier, das ist das eine Lager, die Naherfahrung von Jens Jessen und die muss dann gekontert werden durch Ulf Poschart und das Ganze dann deutschlandweit im Fernsehen. Also hier sind wir wirklich, dass Zizek einfach gesagt hat, wir haben die Wahl zwischen Dummheit und Debilität als Erklärungsmöglichkeit. Das ist der Liegumord.
Und im Prinzip haben wir da eine Situation, ja, wenn zwei Boxer gegeneinander antreten, dann können wir das auch im Fernsehen beobachten, aber man kommt nicht zu der Idee, dass sich also gerade in diesem Boxkampf, der Kampf Deutschlands, der innerhalb Deutschlands gekämpft wird, dann ausgetragen wird im Ring, sondern man sieht davon nur zwei Boxer zusammen. Und hier aber sind die dann so stellvertretend plötzlich da, als Sprecher Ulf Poschert für 50, 60 Prozent der Bevölkerung. Indem man das natürlich permanent wiederholt, identifiziert sich irgendwann auch das Publikum so und glaubt, da habe ich endlich wieder meinen Fürsprecher Ulf Poschert, der ist nämlich auch gegen Claudia Roth. Und damit ist aber gleichzeitig, man kann ja gegen Claudia Roth sein, ich bin sehr dafür sogar, aber man glaube ich muss diese Identifikation nicht mitmachen, die aber angelegt ist da ja eigentlich. Die ist angelegt darin, dass wir dann eigentlich permanent da die Repräsentanten von uns drin sehen sollen, was sie aber definitiv nicht sind, sondern sie repräsentieren ihre Bereiche in dieser kleinen Zunf.
Ja, also jeder ist jetzt medial, nur noch Anwalt für irgendwen. Und selbst wenn er das nicht will, würde er halt als Quoten und dann Bindestrich eingeladen. Und jetzt beziehen wir das auf die aktuelle Diskussion in Amerika. Denn nur so finde ich, macht es überhaupt Sinn, darüber zu reden. Außer man macht sehr gutes Comedy. So wie John Stewart heute Morgen. Das war ja phänomenal. Oder nee, nicht heute Morgen. Nein, falls er darauf reagierte. Wir beginnen mal hier bei Ben Shapiro. Also, wir sind jetzt bei dem Ulf Poschart. Nur halb so alt in Amerika, aber zehnfach großes Publikum. Hardcore. Ja, was eigentlich? Und ich sage, Inhalte interessieren uns jetzt nicht unbedingt, denn uns geht es jetzt darum, wie wir hier heraushören, wie diese Leute die Landschaft sehen, in der sie medial oder wie auch immer tätig sind. Und das wird hier bei Ben Shapiro ganz deutlich. Dieses Gespräch bei Esra Klein wurde vor dem Mord an Charlie Kirk aufgezeichnet, aber erst danach gesendet. Das ist natürlich irgendwie, man weiß gar nicht, in welchem Modus man das jetzt hören soll. Also man kann ja nicht den Mord jetzt ausblenden und so. Also ganz merkwürdig. Und sie gehen mal auf das große Ganze. Zu sprechen, warum gibt es überhaupt zwei Lager? Ben Shapiro hat ein Buch geschrieben über Löwen und Aasfresser. Kommen wir gleich noch zu. Und hier wird einmal beschrieben, also Mamdami zum Beispiel, der jetzt in New York als Bürgermeister antritt, ist natürlich voll die linke Socke, ist ja klar. Diese Verortung liegt auf der Hand, aber bei so anderen Verortungen kann man irgendwie nicht mitgehen. Aber die Selbstverständlichkeit, in der er das macht, zeigt, nur weil es einen Hegemon gibt, heißt das noch lange nicht, dass die einen denselben Hegemon vor sich sehen wie die anderen und dabei einfach nur das Vorzeichen umdrehen. Sondern das sind wirklich ganz unterschiedliche Welten.
If you're asking who represents the left in America, that would probably be the person to come up with.
I mean, I think there's a case that Zoran Mamdani represents the left in America increasingly.
I would also say Zoran Mamdani is motivated by desire to create free buses and rent free cities.
I don't think that's right.
Okay, so, but let's...
Ich glaube nicht, dass das wahr ist. Also, beim Damir ist doch jetzt der neue Hegemon der Linken. Und er sagt extra klein, ne, da wäre einfach nur, dass das Busfahren billiger ist. Ja, also weiter kann man gar nicht auseinander liegen. Jetzt reden sie über andere politische Player.
Stay on the right for a second, the counterrevolutionary side of it. What's the difference between being a conservative and a counterrevolutionary?
Well, I mean, I think that being a conservative is rooted in basic principles, private property, rule of law, traditional virtue. Localism, subsidiarity.
Also, Standardliste, rule of law, irgendwie hier da alles, woran wir uns so gewöhnt haben. Und jetzt nennt er Figuren, die dafür stehen.
The power among the branches of the government. These were all the things that I grew up with as a conservative. And I think that, obviously President Trump is post-ideological. That is for sure.
Donald Trump is post-ideological. That's for sure.
Ach so, das ist mir noch gar nicht aufgefallen.
Also das ist sozusagen der neutrale Hegemon, der einfach nur als Richter da steht und sagt, ja, also rule of law, voll gegeben durch Donald Trump, er hat diese ganzen Eigentumsverquickungen, keine Gier, nichts und so. Nö, das ist absolut sicher. Genau, das ist post-ideologisches.
And what that means is that the right has become sort of a repository for anti-left feeling and is now a big tent. And you know, what I would say is the problem with a big tent is you let in a lot of clowns. And so, yeah, obviously there are tendencies on the right. I don't think it's the overwhelming majority of the right, but I think it is a growing tendency on the right to sort of react to the world with a mentality of grievance that can then translate into a desire to rip things out by their roots.
Ja, also bis hierher, ich verstehe, was er sagt, ich höre die Worte und sie ergeben auch so einen intrinsischen Zusammenhängen und so weiter. Aber das hat, also ich weiß nicht, welche Welt das sein soll. Das ist Fiction einfach. Und das wird auch nicht besser, nur dadurch, dass er das mit historischen Markern irgendwie so, ja, der Name Obama hier, 2012, sagt er, ist die ganz große Wahl gewesen mit Romney da. Wir hören das jetzt mal, wie das hier entfaltet wird. Also wir hören jetzt den Jens-Jessen-artigen. Die Linken sind auch selber schuld und ich verstehe gar nicht, warum ich euch das noch erklären muss. So ungefähr, ja. Aus dem Munde von Ben Shapiro.
So, he wins, Obamacare.
Obama gewinnt 2012, also nicht 2008. Er sagt 2008 hat ja Obama noch den großen, wir sind alle Amerikaner-Wahlkampf geführt, aber 2012 eben nicht mehr. Sondern da ist er gegen mit Romney, mit so, okay, die Schwarzen spreche ich so an, die Latino spreche ich so an, die Asiaten spreche ich so an. Also da hat er sozusagen das eigene Bild, das gemeinsam Amerika verraten. Und das ist jetzt der Ursprung des ganzen Übels bis heute.
Das ist ja eine These, die zunächst einmal weit verbreitet war, aber die gar nicht jetzt Obama zum Vorwurf gemacht wurde. Aber es gibt ja von Kuklik dieses Buch, Die granulare Gesellschaft. Und da ging es ja tatsächlich darum, dass mit diesem Wahlkampf, der die Social-Media-Daten ausgewertet hat, dann man sagen konnte, dort ist jemand, der zweifelt noch, ob er die Demokraten wählen soll. Für den ist aber der öffentliche Nahverkehr das wichtigste Thema. Das wissen wir aus seinen Social-Media-Aktivitäten. Also klopfen wir und konfrontieren ihn nur dort mit diesem Thema und nicht mit allgemeindemokratischen Wahlkampfideen, die wir sonst noch haben.
Und bei Mensch na Piro entfaltet das einfach so.
ObamaCare happens, there's a big blowback in the form of the Tea Party. And he reacts to that by essentially polarizing the electorate. He decides that instead of kind of broadcasting to the general electorate, a sort of optimistic message about America, that he is going to narrow cast his election in 2012. He's going to base it on a much more identity groups rooted politics. He's going to appeal to black Americans as black Americans and gay Americans as gay Americans and Latino Americans as Latino Americans. And there are a lot of articles coming out at this time about essentially demographics is destiny and there's going to be a new minority majority coalition in the United States. And Mitt Romney, who is the most milquetoast and probably as a personally clean candidate in my lifetime, he is characterized as a person who forcibly cuts the hair of gay kids and straps dogs to the top of his car. And he might put y'all back in chains, as Joe Biden said during the campaign. And Mitt Romney loses. And I think that the parties take away from that precisely the wrong messages. They take away the same message, but then they manifest it differently. The message taken away by the Democratic Party is, we have an unbeatable coalition, this new coalition that Barack Obama has forged in 2012, in which he lost votes from 2008, but he still maintained a very solid majority. This is the way forward. We will never lose again because we will be able to cobble together a majority minority coalition, some college educated white people, particularly female, and we're never going to lose again. And Republicans took away exactly the same message, which was no matter how milk toast we run, no matter how clean the candidate. We're gonna get ripped up and down. We're just demographically losing the argument. And so what Republicans came away with was, we're just gonna throw whatever against the wall. The big problem here is that Mitt Romney was simply too nice a guy. We need to run the biggest pulsating middle finger that we can. That pulsating middle finger is Donald Trump.
Obama war einfach, der hätte mit Romney einfach, der war doch voll der gute Kandidat. Warum ist du selber schuld?
Ich will einen Punkt unterstützen, wenn ich dann aber auch in eine andere Richtung gehe als Shapiro. Was wir schon feststellen konnten in den 10er Jahren, ich sehe das aber gar nicht so bei Obama, sondern bei anderen politischen Bewegungen oder auch innerhalb der Demokraten natürlich war, dass und Omri Böhm beschreibt das ja auch in seinem Buch über den radikalen Universalismus. Man anfing nicht mehr zu argumentieren einfach, sondern erst einmal sagte ich als und dann beschrieb man die eigene Identität und darauf kam das Argument. Damit entsteht natürlich eine Tribalisierung der Diskussion, weil man plötzlich nicht mehr auf einer argumentativen Grundlage zunächst ist, sondern erstmal kommen da verschiedene Identitäten zusammen und clashing vielleicht auch aufeinander. Und das ist etwas, was wir dann aber überall beobachten können. Und dann wird es natürlich sehr schwer, wenn ich dann wieder sagen will, ich bin der Präsident von allen oder so. Aber wenn man sich zum Beispiel Peter Thiel anhört, der seinen großen Auftritt dahinlegt bei den Republikanern damals, dann macht er genau das auch und sagt, ich als schwuler Mann, ich unterstütze die Republikaner, unterstütze Donald Trump. Also das können wir dort genauso finden.
Ja, also ich habe ja damals über diesen 2012er-Fahrkampf auch in einer FAZ-großen Aufmache im Vöter geschrieben. Also der einzige Text, der am Tag eins mehr als 1000 Tweets ausgelöst hat, weil Julius Van der Laar im Google-Büro davon erzählte, wie das gelangt. Dieses Get out the vote in Ohio hatte das als Director organisiert. Und da kommt genau das, was du beschreibst. Also da wird nicht mehr die allgemeine Ansprache, sondern da ist so eine komische App, die einfach sagt, klingel mal an dieser Tür, da wohnt jemand, der hat einen Hund und er arbeitet so und so. Also sollte der erste Satz so und so lauten. Und danach wird ganz particularistisch einfach ganz particular, granular durchgepaugt in der Hoffnung, dass derjenige zu überzeugen ist. Aber das große Bild Amerikase findet da nicht statt. Diese Kritik ist also berechtigt. Aber hier bei Ben Shapiro geht das in eine andere Richtung, denn der große Fehler Obamas war, ein particularistisches, particulares Interesse herauszuholen. Nämlich, er hat darauf hingewiesen, dass es in Amerika Rassismus gegen Schwarze gibt. Ach so. Und das ist natürlich kein Wunder, dass dann die Rechten drauf kamen zu sagen, nee, das stimmt doch gar nicht.
When I look back on that, and the beer summit in particular, to hear like, that's what radicalized you all?
Yes. And the reason is, because the implicit promise of Barack Obama was the worst conflict in the history of America, which is the racial history of the United States, which is truly horrifying. That in his person, he was basically going to be the capstone of the great movement toward Martin Luther King's dream. And when instead things seemed to move in the opposite direction, which was, well, it turns out that black people in America, they're inherently victimized by a system, by a white supremacist system that puts black people underfoot. And my son could have been Trayvon. And people on the right saw that as like, well, but that's not true. You are an upper class black man who is living in the White House. And unless your son was mistaken for a prowler going around at night in a neighborhood, then no, that actually wouldn't happen to your son. In fact, you have two black daughters and that stuff has never happened to them.
Also der Punkt ist, Obama ergreift in einer Rede das Wort als ich rede, zumal stellvertretend für den Vater, der seinen Sohn verloren, der Sohn war schwarz. Also, es hätte auch mein Sohn sein können. Und dann stehen die einfach da und sagen, es ist doch voll das Quatschargument, du hast doch zwei Töchter und die geht es doch voll gut. Wie kannst denn du dir den Hegemon so auf deine Seite ziehen wollen?
Wo wir bei Konservativen jetzt beobachten, dass sie jedes Mal ihre Kinder anführen als Argument für Irgendetwas.
The sort of, Michael Brown in Ferguson, the idea that when the president went out and he said that people wouldn't just make this up. And it turns out actually that a lot of it was made up.
It kind of sounds like that the interpretation of Obama, at least to you, was that if he is elected, we'll agree we've gotten past all this. Like it's supposed to make us feel better. And then when it didn't, like that was understood as the betrayal of a promise.
Well, I mean, again, that is how I think most Americans saw it, including black Americans.
That was...
Ben Shapiro so einfach. Nee, ich glaube, das war, wie es die meisten Amerikaner dachten, auch die Schwarzen. Also, mehr Hegemon-Argumentation kann man gar nicht. Das ist wieder Jens Jessen mit seinem... Aber es ist doch klar, dass man so denkt, ja. Also, dass jemand anders denken könnte, war da gar nicht.
It was a widespread sentiment, not just among white Americans, among black Americans, is that something had gone radically wrong in 2013, 2014. So something happened. And this was an argument that was made by legacy media a lot.
Jaja, Leute hatten also was gegen diesen Elgemann, den Obama für sich reklamierte. Also, Elgemann im Sinne von, wer hat hier welche Rechtfertigungspflichten? Oder kamen die Rechte und meinten, hey, wir müssen dort so und sich dafür rechtfertigen.
The point is that the perception by people who were not actually picking on Barack Obama because of his race, or were picking on him because of his politics, was that suddenly everything was being refracted through a racial lens.
And how do you understand the birther thing?
You mean the public resonance of the birther thing on the right?
Ja, also er fragt dann auch bei so konkreten Sachfragen. Nur noch, ja, geht es jetzt gerade da oben um die public perception, also wie die Öffentlichkeit das verstanden hat, dass er zur Sache reden muss. Ist für ihn schon, also welcher Pirodoktor nur noch an diesem Hegemon ruft.
Ja, und das ist ja diese Idee, die oft von Konservativen, also nicht nur von jetzt so radikal Rechten vertreten wird, es ist ja die Ideologiefreiheit. Ideen statt Ideologie heißt ein Buch von Julia Klöckner. Will noch mal dran erinnern. Und da ist ja immer was da mitschwingt. Wir sind eigentlich der neutrale Rahmen und die anderen, die kommen und wollen da ihre Hegemonie ausbreiten, wollen hegemonial werden, indem sie plötzlich sagen, Rassismus ist ein Problem in der Gesellschaft. Damit verlassen sie ja die Neutralität. Also sagen sie, generell gibt es da also nicht nur einfach eine Neutralität, in der alles in Ordnung ist, sondern da gibt es Rassismus. Oh wei, da müssen wir jetzt dagegenhalten, also gegen diese aufscheinende Hegemonie von rechts. Und dann setzt man eben die andere dagegen. Und da muss man glaube ich nochmal diesen Begriff der Hegemonie klären, weil der eigentlich zweierlei meint. Also einmal ist das ja ein Begriff, mit dem man in der Geopolitik operiert, um das Verhältnis zu beschreiben, das Zwischenstaaten vorliegt. Also zum Beispiel die USA sind nach 89 der Hegemonen, Weltpolizei und so weiter. Und dann ist die Frage, haben wir jetzt so einen Kampf von verschiedenen Hegemonien, unterschiedlicher Hegemonien mit Russland, China, USA, wo steht da eigentlich Europa? Und dann kann man aber sehen, es gibt diesen Hegemoniebegriff auch innerstaatlich. Und da ist die Frage, wer hat da die Vorherrschaft in Sachen Meinung? Und das basiert natürlich sehr stark auf Gramsci. Und der wird ja sowohl von links gelesen, er ist ja ein Linker, ist aber dann auch von Rechten rezipiert worden, auch von der identitären Bewegung. Dass man sich also die Frage stellt, wie können wir diskursiv eine Vorherrschaft erlangen, dass zum Beispiel alle nur noch über Messerstecher reden. Und wenn wir das erreicht haben, so jetzt eine rechte Argumentation von oder eine rechte Hegemoniestrategie, dann ist es für uns leicht, irgendwann tatsächlich auch die politische Macht zu übernehmen, gewählt zu werden, Institutionen zu besetzen. Und was jetzt ja gerade stattfindet, ist, dass eben nicht ein neutraler Wahn wiederhergestellt wird, wie denn auch, sondern es gibt eben unterschiedlich widerstreitende hegemoniale Kämpfe. Und gerade sind die Rechten sehr dabei, sie zu gewinnen. Hier ist es interessant, dass sie einen anderen Weg machen, als der ursprünglich von Gramsci mal so angedachte, sie machen nicht erstmal kulturelle Hegemonie und dann haben sie die politische Macht. Klar gibt es auch diese Sachen mit Joe Rogan in Podcasts und so, aber wir sehen jetzt gerade, wo die politische Macht da ist und die Machtfülle größer wird, fangen sie jetzt nochmal richtig an, kulturelle Hegemonie auf Teufel komm raus herzustellen, indem sie dann zum Beispiel den Kimmel entlasten.
Zum Beispiel? Also wir haben uns auch schon über lustig gemacht, dass Münkler sagt, wir haben keine regelbasierte Ordnung mehr, sondern jetzt ist nur noch Macht. Und wir korrigieren dann und sagen, nee, es war schon immer Macht, weil das mit der Regelbasierung war ja gerade das Machtvolle, nur eben des Hegemons.
Genau.
Alle anderen mussten sich unterordnen. Und so ist das hier ein bisschen auch. Also den Hegemon kann man einfach in den Raum stellen. Aber auf zweiter Ebene, also da, wo dann die Regelbasierung irgendwie festgemacht werden muss, da wird es dann kompliziert, auch bei Ben Shapiro. Also Esra Klein fragt hier gut nach zum neuen Buch. Das heißt Lions und Scavengers. Also es gibt Löwen, die machen die Arbeit noch selbst. Und dann gibt es diese Aasfresser. Der größte Aasfresser ist Bernie Sanders. Der hat ja noch nie was selber gemacht, der will immer nur anderen Leuten das wegnehmen. Aufgrund irgendwelcher Ideen. So, und jetzt lässt Israq Layan erstmal dieses Bild entfalten. Was ist mit diesem Ars-Fresser gemeint?
But so your view is sort of basically any politician, left or right, who says to people, listen, you're suffering. You don't make enough. You're working two or three jobs to get by or not finding jobs. And the reason is that you got screwed. We shipped your job to China, the trade deals were unfair, or the billionaires took too much, and now you've got just-in-time scheduling in a community that doesn't have a paper mill anymore. That whenever you sort of activate that sense, that it's not your fault, it's their fault. That's scavenger mentality to you.
I think generally speaking, that is true unless you can provide very, very good evidence that there is a cause and effect relationship between the thing that you are blaming and the thing that is happening to the person.
Also, ich werde konkret darüber gesprochen, wer muss ich für was rechtfertigen? Wenn dir etwas geschieht, wie du verlierst deinen Platz, weil irgendwie dein Arbeitsplatz, weil keine Autos mehr hergestellt werden, keine Kohle mehr, der ganze alte Kram und so, dann soll man kein Recht haben, Ansprüche zu stellen, weil der Hegemon sagt dir einfach nur, ja gut, also du bist selber schuld. So, das ist dieser Hegemon, wie ihn sich Ben Shapiro vorstellt und dagegen steht eben dieser Sozialstaatsgedanke, dass man einfach sagt, nee, jetzt ist mir niemand selber schuld, sondern wir versuchen einfach alles das Beste daraus zu machen mit irgendwelchen Entscheidungen in der Bildungsbiografie und danach, wo man arbeitet, wie auch immer. Dann gerät man halt in Branchen, die es irgendwann nicht mehr gibt und dann unterstützt man halt. Schon allein wollen wir die Arbeitskräfte auch woanders braucht, statt sie einfach nur Death of Despair oder der Brücker oder wie auch immer. Jetzt hat Ben Shapiro das einmal so dargestellt. Und jetzt macht Israel Kleine eine sehr gute Nachfrage, wo man sofort sieht, ja, diese segemoniale Denken und so weiter. Wer muss hier weben welche Rechtfertigung? Wer darf welche Ansprüche äußern? Das hält überhaupt gar nicht stand, vor allem nicht jetzt gerade bei diesem Zeitgeist.
And if you fail, you know, that ain't always everybody else's problem.
How do you understand the pitch Donald Trump or the course of his political career made to his voters? Right, because I would say a real way that he differed from Mitt Romney was it, he came and said, you got screwed.
Yes.
And so-
I think he's wrong, but yes.
And so he pulled the right into a scavenger mentality?
I think with regard to sort of a populist economics, yes, sure.
You seem pretty positive on him a lot to feel that way. Like you voted for him in 2020 and 2024. You campaigned for him in 2024.
Right. I'm happy to explain my evolution with President Trump. I didn't vote for either candidate in 2016. I voted for him in 2020. I campaigned for him in 2024. Yes. That doesn't mean I agree with him on everything.
I actually want to be super clear. I understand your evolution is interesting. I don't want to do a gotcha interview with you. I'm actually tracking it because I think it is important to understand you to understand the right. The reason I'm actually surprised to hear you say some of this isn't that I couldn't map it onto the theory of the book, but that the way you write about scavengers in the book, it's so vicious, it's so subhuman.
So, Esra Klein sagt ihm, so wie du über die Aasfresser schreibst, die du dieser Gesellschaft unterstellst, Leute, die den Sozialstaat, da sie ihn in Anspruch nehmen, schon missbrauchen und so weiter, die über nur irgendwen anders als Schuldigen sehen. Das ist so eine Sprache, die mich emotional erkalten lässt. Es ist wirklich erschüttert darüber, wie krass Ben Shapiro das schreibt. Aber auf die Nachfrage hin, aber ist nicht Trump der größte Aasfresser? Sagt dann Shapiro selbst? Ja, ich stimme ja nicht mit allem überein, nur ich denke mir, diese Aasfresser-Mentalität von Trump ist ja wirklich zu 100 Prozent das, was Trump ausmacht. Da gibt es ja nichts weiteres, neben Crypto-Creed, hier Machtmissbrauch und der ganze Kram.
Aber wie erklärst du dir, dass Vanessa Klein das ja hier richtigerweise ausführt und auch erschüttert ist über diesen Ton, dass er dann zugleich einen Artikel über Charlie Kirk schreibt, in dem er sagt, ja, wir waren uns in allen Punkten uneins, aber wir wollten doch eigentlich beide dasselbe, nämlich ein gutes Amerika. Also sind da nicht, also ich zweifle so langsam an den Verstand der Liberalen. Und bei Scott Galloway gab es ja ähnliche Kommentaren in seinem Podcast, dass ich dann so den Eindruck habe, ja, also worum geht es jetzt? Also generell, weil man sich noch so allgemein patriotisch gibt, reicht aus. Also dann kann ich sagen, ja, ich bin irgendwie ganz froh, wenn hier in Deutschland alles seinen Weg geht und Höcke auch. Also wir sind uns zwar an allen Punkten uneins, aber da haben wir doch eine große Gemeinsamkeit. Also ich verstehe nicht, was diese komische Fraternisierung da jetzt soll, wo man dann sagen kann, ja, also klar, Charlie Kirk hat jetzt nicht mit den Chinesen unter einer Decke gesteckt oder so. Das kann man ihm vielleicht nicht vorwerfen. Also sonst fast alles, aber das nicht. Und das reicht aber irgendwie schon aus, um zu sagen, am Ende sind wir ja alle Patrioten oder was. Also ich finde diesen amerikanischen Liberalismus auch sehr gespenstisch, weil der so eine unglaubliche Verharmlosung dann am Ende vornimmt, dass man dann sagt, wir hatten so ein paar unsere Dispute. Dann würde ich sagen, es ist schon ein existenzieller Disput, ob ich Frauen, Transpersonen, nicht weißen Menschen ihre Grundrechte bereit bin, abzusprechen oder überhaupt sie zur Disposition zu stellen. Also das wird ja immer nur in Form der Frage gemacht. Aber ich meine, wenn man schon die Frage stellt, müssen Frauen eigentlich gleichberechtigt sein? Dann ist ja schon in der Frage alles falsch. Ja, dass man da jetzt sagt, naja, aber sonst im Grunde waren wir uns dann doch eins. Das ist ja nicht eine Uneinigkeit, wie man sie sonst unter Demokraten hat, dass man sagt, gut, ich will zwei Prozent Mehrwertsteuer weniger, der andere will drei Prozent mehr. Da kann man sagen, da sind wir uns so uneinig, aber doch im Ganzen darauf ausgerichtet, dass wir eine gute Volkswirtschaft haben wollen.
Also ich hör auf die Frage, warum hat Esra Klein diesen Text geschrieben, sagen er wollte sich einfach persönlich aus der Schusslinie bringen und vielleicht auch ein bisschen die New York Times.
Aber das ist schon auch erschreckend.
In Amerika regiert ein Diktator und es ist Bürgerkrieg.
Ja, aber man kann auch dachten, man hat das Position, also aus der liberalen, ich war gestern in Lübeck und wir haben über Thomas Manns Intervention zur Demokratie gesprochen, der war ja dann doch weitaus mutiger und der war nicht von Kind auf Demokrat, um das mal so auszudrücken.
Ja, allerdings, also diese Vorwürfe kann man jetzt machen. Wir springen ins Deutsche, Matze hat in Hotel Matze Harald Wälzer zu Gast. Und auch da fragt man sich so ein bisschen, klingt schon mal gut, ja. Was ist mit diesem Hegemon los? Woran orientieren sich Leute? Also wir haben immer noch Minderkopf, der Dumme, der Debile, wie auch immer. Wir hören mal eine Antwort von Wälzer auf eine. Und wir wissen ja, wie Matze so seine Fragen stellt.
Ich bin ja auch total als Pazifist groß geworden. Und das geht ja jetzt plötzlich als, das geht ja gar nicht. Geht überhaupt nicht. Ja. Und wenn ich sage, also ich weiß nicht, ob man da ein Waffen schicken soll oder nicht. Ich bin nicht der Richtige dafür. Also muss ich doch auf eine Seite und so weiter und so fort. Wie ist es dazu gekommen? Und was geht da an den Köpfen vor?
Das ist die Frage, die wir jetzt offen haben. Sind die alle dumm oder debil, die jetzt irgendwie Werbpflicht fordern oder was auch immer?
Das ist das, was geht da an den Köpfen vor?
Vielleicht kann man es so hart sagen, in den Köpfen geht gar nichts vor. Sondern es gibt so einfach Entwicklungen, wo das, was man so sagt, wie man die Dinge so sieht, das ist so das, was man dann so sagt und wie man die Dinge so sieht. Das sind der Gruppenprozesse.
Das ist die Definition des Debilen, wie er das sehr gut beschreibt.
Da ist der Hegemann einfach, man geht in so einen Raum und denkt, alle sehen nach Journalismus aus. Ah ja, das ist ein Zeitkongress. Kein Wunder. Ich bin natürlich für die Werbpflicht. Ich verbrenne mir doch jetzt hier nicht die Finger. Ich habe dieses Wort, ich steh greif. Ich weiß nicht, was das genau bedeutet. Das heißt, steh greif, steh greif.
Steh greif, das ist ja eigentlich, wenn ich richtig unterrichtet bin, ich habe nur einmal in meinem Leben auf dem Pferd gesessen. Aber das ist doch eigentlich der, wo man so einschaltet und dann geht man rauf aufs Pferd, oder?
Stimmt das?
Ach, das ist der Steigbügel, Entschuldigung. Steh greif. Also es gibt ja das Steh greif Theater.
Also man sagt ja so Ausruf Steh greif.
Das ist so das Impro Theater. Ja, da kommen wir natürlich jetzt, das kann jetzt mal jeder noch zu Hause nachgucken.
Genau. Also offene Frage.
So eine schöne.
Es ist eigentlich auch ein bisschen witzig.
Also eigentlich kriege ich ja sowas morgens beim Frühstück bei SWR 4 erklärt. Da erklären die meisten solche.
Dass wir nicht genau wissen, was der Steh greif ist, die Steh greif, der Steh greif, wie auch immer, finde ich auch ein bisschen witzig, weil das meint ja dieses Wort etwas aus dem Steh greif. Man weiß gar nicht warum. Es ist so Muscle Memory. Keine Ahnung, der Vibe sagt, wer pflegt, ist doch klar. So, Steigbügel.
Steigbügel, man ist noch nicht richtig drin. Man ist noch nicht richtig drin. Man macht so mal schnell Theater, also stehkräftig.
Ah ja, so, siehste.
Wir wiederholen das nochmal, man ist noch nicht vom Pferd abgestiegen, aber man antwortet schon, also man ist ganz spontan unterwegs.
Genau, man brüllt die Essensbestellung schon, während man noch vom Pferd springt, weil man genau weiß, was man essen will. Ja. So, man geht mit dem Pflug.
Oder sagt wer pflegt jetzt, weil man schon weiß, ihr freut sich alle, wenn sie das hören.
Ja, also in den Köpfen geht gar nichts vor. Welchen Kopf genau meint Wälzer in einem Gespräch mit Matze?
Kannst du mit, also das ist auf jeden Fall ein Thema, was mir während der Wahl, da hab ich auch.
Also eben war ja Wärmpflicht, jetzt kommt das nächste Thema, dass alle aus dem Steg greifen mit einer Meinung und so weiter.
Wie oft wird dieses Thema behandelt? Das war ganz, hast du ja auch schon gesagt, gegenwärtig. Und jetzt aktuell ist es das Bürgergeld, finde ich. Und ich verstehe es tatsächlich nicht. Also wenn man sich wirklich so was wie Zahlen anguckt oder Fakten anguckt, dann gibt es das Thema doch eigentlich überhaupt nicht her, wenn wir sagen, okay, das sind wir haben finanzielle Herausforderungen, wie wir in Start-up sagen. Und die müssen wir irgendwie lösen. Und dann reden wir so sehr über das Bürgergeld. Und das kriege ich nicht. Ich kriege es nicht zusammen. Warum das, wie das gelingt, dass das so ein Thema wird, wie das gesetzt wird und dass alle das auch inklusive Medien, alles, das wird einfach die ganze Zeit weitergetragen. Aber im großen Kuchen, vielleicht übersehe ich da was.
Naja, aber du musst dich ja nicht dümer stellen, als du bist. Es hat natürlich eine Funktion. Weil wenn du ein Thema, was gar keins ist, großmachst politisch, brauchst du über andere Themen nicht mehr so intensiv zu reden. Und da, wo du nichts auf Tasche hast, redest du auch nicht so gerne drüber.
Das verstehe ich.
Ah, das versteht er. Also man wählt politisch natürlich nur Themen, bei denen man sich dem Rückhalt des Hegemon sicher ist. Wer arbeiten kann, muss arbeiten. Zustimmungsquote Politbarometer 85 Prozent. Also redet man übers, also leitet man daraus das Bürgergeld ab, wo ich mir denke, okay, also Bürgergeld kriegen Kinder, Kranke und so weiter. Die könnten alle keine Ahnung was, also Kinderarbeit wollen wir nicht halten. Matze ist überrascht. Wir hören jetzt einfach so den Redefluss und dann macht Matze, er baut es eigentlich so ein, oder Wälzer sagt etwas oder lässt so eine Idee mitschleifen. Er macht es gar nicht zu konkret, aber irgendwann fällt es Matze dann auf. Aber der Helfer, man sagt doch gerade, ist irgendwie anders. Also das habe ich so noch gar nicht im Heuterschneid gesehen.
Wir sehen schon neue Dinge. Wir sehen ja die Entstehung eines totalitären Systems, was keine Ideologie jenseits des Geldes hat. Das ist zum Beispiel was Neues. Also ein kommunistisches System, das Jovets-System hat eine Ideologie gehabt. Ja. Ja? Kommunismus, Sozialismus, Befreiung des Welt... So, Nationalsozialismus hat eine Ideologie gehabt. Ja, arische Weltherrschaft und so weiter. Das, was wir dort jetzt sehen im Entstehen, ist ja ideologiefrei. Also jenseits des Aspekts, dass das Recht des Stärkeren total super ist und dass es um Kohle geht. Was anderes ist da ja nicht drin.
Es gibt keine Werte mehr, meinst du?
Nein. Also selbst ein anderer Diktator, der Kollege Putin, hat ja eine Ideologie.
Würdest du sagen, ein anderer Diktator, würdest du sagen, dass Trump ein Diktator ist?
Na ja, auf alle Fälle.
Okay.
Na ja, also ich bin ja mit diesen Begriffen auch ein wenig vorsichtig, weil wir ja doch bei Donald Trump die Möglichkeit der Abwahl noch vor uns sehen können, weil Putin, Wälzer sieht das ja anders. Ja, ja, der kann das ja so sehen, aber ich sehe da doch einen qualitativen Unterschied noch zu Putin. Da sehe ich jetzt nicht, dass bei der nächsten Wahl es nochmal spannend wird, ob Putin nochmal gewählt wird.
Genau.
Den Eindruck habe ich bislang nicht.
Und das ist aber jetzt dieser Punkt. Es ist erstens ein zukünftiges Ereignis, zweitens inhaltlicher, ehe egal. Jetzt kann man nicht darüber reden. Die Frage ist nur, im Gespräch muss sich derjenige der rechtfertigen, der sagt, wie abgewählt, wann soll denn die Wahl stattfinden? Erklär mir das mal. Na, Amerika ist doch eine Demokratie, da gibt es auch einen Wahltermin. Hä, verstehe ich nicht, ja. Oder geht man noch ins Gespräch rein wie Matze, ja, glaube, der ist abgewählt, weil er ist noch zwei Amtszeiten rum. Also es geht nur um die Rechtfertigungsbericht. Es geht nicht um die Fakten. Wir hören noch einen Clip, der ist jetzt deutsche Politik. Matze und die Linken, er sympathisiert da so ein bisschen, aber er weiß nicht so genau.
Und ich weiß nicht mehr...
Er ist im Grunde dieses Gerätsel. Was sagt der Hegemann zur Linkspartei?
Und ich weiß nicht mehr... Also es ist viel mehr auch schwer, bei der letzten Wahl mein Kreuz irgendwo hinzumachen, weil ich nicht mehr weiß. Und das ist jetzt wieder weniger geworden sogar. Dann habe ich da am Ende die Linke gewählt. Und merke aber auch irgendwie diese Kümmerstaatidee und die Reichen, die Reichen, die Reichen als ein Feinbild aufzubauen. Ich fühl's nicht so. Und jetzt merke ich, okay, jetzt bin ich gerade politisch total heimatlos. Und ich weiß aber auch gar nicht, welche Art von Staat soll ich denn eigentlich wollen? Was ist denn das Beste?
Weißt du das?
Aber was soll dann Harald Wälzer da jetzt helfen? Da muss man ja fast sagen, kommt man an meinen Arm.
Ja, im Grunde braucht hier jemand eine Hegemann-Betreuung. Also jetzt nicht in Inhalte ausweichen, sondern erstmal an der Beziehungsstruktur arbeiten und so weiter.
Also das ist der Hegemann vom Cover, der kommt dann und nimmt einen an den Arm.
Wollte man das auf eine innertliche Ebene ziehen, obwohl jetzt ein bisschen Zeit verschwendet wurde durch Computer und so weiter. Es gibt einen zwei Minuten langen Clip, der sehr gut passt. Wir springen zurück ins Englische. Wir hören jetzt Corey Doctorow genau auf diese Frage. Also wir lassen jetzt nicht Wälzers Antwort gewähren, sondern wir hören einen der klügsten politischen Kommentatoren der Gegenwart zu dieser Frage, die Bösen, die anderen, der Reichtum, der Hegemann, was ist zu tun? In Podcast QNN, falls jemand kennt, QAA heißt das, das ist sehr gut.
This is a very profound observation, because if you observe that the finance sector has a parasitic relationship with the productive economy and that because it is able to kind of leverage what should be a fairly kind of utilitarian role of allocating capital into a kind of market structuring role of controlling and structuring the economy, it gains political power that it can use to enhance its financial power and then its political power and so on. You observe all of this and you say the problem is that the bankers are Jewish. Then you have ascribed individual moral failings to what is a systemic problem, right? You asked me before about Mark Zuckerberg and whether he was an op. I don't think Mark Zuckerberg was an op. I think there was a Mark Zuckerberg shaped hole in the economy because we were allowing monopolization. And in the same way, I don't think that who the bankers are matters. I think that it is the structure of the economy that makes bankers so powerful that matters. And so I spoiled the rest of this interview because I looked ahead in your document. I know we're going to talk about Libs in a bit, but you know, there's a little saying about Libs I like, which is that, Libs observe a world in which 150 straight white men are running everything and say, that's not fair. Half of them should be women, people of color and queers. And, you know, I think that, like, if you are unable to understand that systemic problems arise out of systemic conditions, and you think instead that extraordinary individual villainy is what causes bad things to happen, then you're asking the wrong question. You know, I'm a novelist, I write about villains, right? But the thing that makes villains important is not just their bad ideas, it's their power, right? If Elon Musk didn't have the ability to exploit a bunch of financial loopholes, he'd just be another asshole with bad ideas. You know, it's the half a trillion dollars that makes him an important person. And, you know, there are lots of people with bad ideas out there. If the only way we can make the world better is by making sure that people stop having bad ideas, we're really hosed. But if we can just make sure no one's got half a trillion dollars, which I think is a much smaller lift, then the bad ideas just don't matter in the same way.
Ja, wir sind genervt von diesem Milliardären Die haben halt so einen krassen Zugriff auf den Hegemon. Sobald Elon Musk irgendwie verkündet, ja, ich hab mal die tolle Antwort auf die Frage, was ist das wichtigste Problem der Welt? Von Free Speech ist bedroht auf Demografie geändert. Dann wissen wir, der hat Zugriff auf den Hegemon. Die großen Medienunternehmen, die uns einfach die Abendshows canzeln und so. Niemand kennt diese Namen. Ich meine, du kennst Bob Iger, wer sonst? Jetzt, wo er uns Kimmel gecancelt hat, ist es plötzlich ein Riesenthema. Also es geht immer nur um diesen Hegemon, nicht um Inhalte, nicht in inhaltliche Diskussion gehen, sondern immer den...
Ja, also gerade bei Bob Iger ist es ja ganz interessant. Ich hab ja seine Autobiografie gelesen und dort endet die so ziemlich damit, dass er erzählt, wie sie wirklich einen inklusiven Film machen wollen mit Marvel und dann machen sie Black Panther. Und dann schreibt er einen ganz pathetischen Brief, wie wichtig eben Diversity ist, an die Belegschaft. Und er ist so stolz auf diesen Brief, dass er ihn sogar noch mal in der Autobiografie abdruckt. Und er ist jetzt derjenige, der diese Cancellation vornimmt. Es ist kaum auszuhalten.
Genau. Also wir machen noch drei Clips. Einer davon, den Rest machen wir so gut Ende des Monats, das Thema bleibt ja wohl aktuell. Wir spielen mal diesen zentralen Spruch von Charlie Kirk, bei dem wir alle verstehen, ja, stimmt, hier geht's nicht um Inhalt. Es geht nur um dieses hegemoniale Gerangel.
Turning Point USA, how you doing?
Also, wir hören The Daily. Uns wird, wie allen, nur dort sind sie ehrlich. Uns wird einfach Charlie Kirk vorgestellt als, kanntet ihr bisher nicht, war aber wichtig, war junge Leute, wie auch immer. Während die deutschen Journalisten immer so tun, als kennen sie den seit Geburt. Also, das ist auch ein tolles Medienspektakel.
And what's Kirk's message at these events? And how is he seeking to hit a chord with this specific demographic, especially college students?
Well, I'd say on the one hand, that Kirk's message was mostly indistinguishable from that of Trump.
GDP growth, lowest ever black unemployment, lowest ever Latino unemployment, lowest ever women unemployment. And yet the left is doing everything they can to remove this president. Why? Because they don't just hate him. They hate you. He's just in the way.
Das ist der zentrale Satz. Inhaltlich sagt Charlie Kirk einfach, also klar, der ist ein Rassist, wie auch immer, was alles gewesen ist. Aber er sagt einfach, ist doch alles normal. Also wir haben Arbeitslosigkeit, ist super, das ist super, das ist, das ist, alles ist super. Aber die Linken mit ihrem hegemonialen Druck und so weiter, die uns immer hier den Präsidenten anmahdig machen, ja, und Trump steht für euch in deren Weg. Also mehr hegemoniales Denken geht gar nicht. Ja, also hier spielen Inhalte wirklich gar keine Rolle. Kommen wir nach Deutschland und wie man das kommentiert. Micky Beisenertz hat einen Podcast, ihr kennt ihn alle, Apophika, abgekürzt, Apokalypse und Filtercafé. Zum einen nach dem Tod von Charlie Kirk. Im Podcast reden sie darüber, wie man jetzt über Charlie Kirk redet.
Interessant ist, wenn du ihn jetzt so als Hassprediger darstellen willst, den Charlie Kirk, dann brauchst du gar nicht so lang zu suchen. Natürlich hat er so kontroverse, auch wirklich für mich persönlich schlimme Sachen gesagt. Und trotzdem...
Also auch rechtsextrem, wenn du sagst, oder rassistisch, wenn jemand sagt, ich würde mir genau überlegen, ob ich im Flieger steige, wenn ich weiß, dass der Pilot schwarz ist, weil Schwarze quasi keine Befähigung haben, dann ist es natürlich lukenreiner Rassismus. Da gibt es ja glaube ich kein Rumdeuteln.
Genau, und trotzdem ist die Frage, ob am Tag seiner Ermordung wirklich der richtige Zeitpunkt ist, sowas immer direkt als nächsten Satz zu nennen, wenn du so eine Todesnachricht gerade meldest. Weil so kam es mir dann eben auch bei Dunja Yali, fand ich auch. Es wirkte dann so, er wurde ermordet, er sagte, aber auch diese...
Es war also leicht paraphrasiert war die Anmoderation im Heute-Journal und sie nahm natürlich in gewisser Hinsicht deswegen ja auch eine Wertung vor, war also nichts rechtfertigt die Tat Charlie Kirk zu ermorden, auch nicht die abstoßenden Aussagen, das und das Rechtsextrem.
Und so machen es viele, wie ich in meiner Newsfeed bei Instagram oder so sehe, dieses, ja nichts verteidigt diese Tat, aber man sollte auch erwähnen, wer er war.
Also ein kurzes Ja und schon ein langes Aber und dann schon doch eine Rechtfertigung.
Ja, das ist eine ganz falsche Denkweise. Wer spricht denn da noch?
Seine Frau oder Freundin.
Okay, also folgendes. Wir haben als Wolfgang Schäuble sprach im Podcast sehr deutlich darüber gesprochen, als er starb oder starb. Dass da nicht irgendwie dieser Satz gilt, der sowieso unsinnig übertrote, nur gute ist. Wir können Wolfgang Schäuble, der nicht unser Vater direkt war, mit dem wir nicht verheiratet waren oder so, nur als Politiker erinnern. Und dann kann man sagen, Wolfgang Schäuble hat eine desaströse Politik gemacht, unter der beispielsweise die Griechen sehr gelitten haben, aber auch die Austriitätspolitik in Deutschland war falsch. So zumindest meine Auffassung. Und dies kann ich auch am Tag, als der Tod bekannt gegeben wird, so formulieren. Und genauso, es ist ja selten, dass ich Dona Hayali verteidige, kann auch Dona Hayali sagen, es gehört sich nicht, dass wir Menschen auf der Straße abknallen. Und dann kann sie trotzdem sagen, für was Charlie Kirk stand, weil er ja auch genau dafür stand. Also jetzt nicht nochmal, dass man irgendwo was gesucht hat.
Nur deswegen redet man ja über ihn.
Man ist ja nicht auf die Suche gegangen, finden wir irgendwas, was wir schlecht über Charlie Kirk erzählen können, sondern das hat ihn ja ausgezeichnet in seinem politischen Tun. Und ich verstehe überhaupt nicht, warum man, also wie soll denn sonst, weil wir können uns ja nicht an den Familienvater, den kennen wir nun wirklich gar nicht. Also das ist ja, also man macht ja auch nicht den normalen Tagesschau-Nachruf, hier ist das erste deutsche Fernsehen, Hildegard Knef ist tot, sie war eine wunderbare Mutter und Ehefrau. Da würde man ja sagen, ja und? Das interessiert mich nicht. Hat sie vielleicht gesungen oder einen Film gemacht?
Genau. Es macht ja gar keinen Sinn, eine Person, die die meisten überhaupt nur an, also an diesem Tag überhaupt erst kennenlernt. Und am Tag zwei, und das ist eben, das wird man jetzt in Amerika sehen, so sehr da versucht wird, das zum Top-Thema zu halten und daraus Programme abzuleiten und Effekte und wie auch immer. Aber das wird natürlich sehr schnell vergessen, so wie alles sehr schnell vergessen wird. Und wann anders als an diesem Anlass-Tag über ihn zu reden, sollte man darüber reden. Also es ist ja völlig absurd, nur deswegen reden wir darüber. Weil er tot ist, weil jemand ihn zum Ziel genommen hat, warum zum Ziel.
Ja, es war ja wohl, also wir wissen noch nicht genau, was sich herausstellen wird, aber es war ja ein politischer Mord wohl.
Genau.
Also müssen wir ja über das Politische sprechen, über was soll man dann sonst sprechen da?
Ja, also zu dieser politischen Dimension kommen wir dann heute nicht, aber dann Ende des Monats, darauf zu sprechen, wenn man wirklich nicht versucht, sondern mit Ahnung die Inschriften auf der Munition entziffert, dann hat man auch inhaltliche Diskussionen. Aber dann ist man wo ganz anders als bei dem, was im Medialgrad stattfindet. Also dann wird es wirklich heikel. Wie ist das jetzt in diesem Beisenherz-Podcast, bevor jemand stirbt, also bevor plötzlich der Hegemon Pietät über allem schwebt und sagt, nichts Schlechtes über die Toten, dann klingt es erstens mal viel lockerer und so. Und auch ganz anders. Hier ist Miriam laut zu Gast und man fragt sich und wir reformulieren jetzt mal. Die Frage, die im Raum steht, ist, liebe Miriam, wir sind ja beides politische Beobachter. Wen möchtest du denn als Vorkämpfer für das Zerren am Hegemon zum Beispiel in Bundestagsdebatten künftig gerne sehen? Ja, das ist die Frage, die im Raum steht.
Es wird ja immer so viel geklagt, ach früher und wehner und das war so toll. Ich würde mal sagen, die Quote war wahrscheinlich damals wie heute von guten Rhetorikern. Es kommen immer mal wieder welche nach. Trittin ist weg, dafür haben wir jetzt Heidi Reichenegg. Ja, ich finde, da kann man an Eleganz auch noch, aber...
Also hier ist übrigens nur Stilkritik, die ja gerade total verboten war. So im Sinne von Heidi Reichenegg ist eine Frau, die wir erstmal als Person waren. Nein, da wird gleich auf die Stilkritik abgestellt.
Ja, also, wer fällt mir denn ein? Wem höre ich gerne zu?
Muss man schon ein bisschen überlegen, ne? Ich überlege auch gar. Amtor ist eigentlich gar nicht so schlecht.
Amtor gehört wirklich zu den verblüffenderweise unterschätzten...
So, verblüffend unterschätzt. Jetzt hat sich Philipp Amtor schon genannt. Das ist schon ein Witz für sich, aber sie schiebt jetzt noch eine Begründung hinterher.
Verblüffenderweise unterschätzten Politikern. Ich finde bei dem auch sehr gut diese Momente, wenn der sich so mit der AfD anlegt.
Ja, da hat er legendäre Reden gehalten. Ja, das stimmt.
Ganz genau. Und dieser kühle Zorn.
Ah ja, kühler Zorn wird plötzlich für die Arena gewünscht. Also davon habe ich die letzte Woche gar nichts gehört.
Ja. Nee, nee, wir müssen uns jetzt mal wieder alle vertragen, um dann aber wieder zornig zu sein, wenn jemand von der anderen Seite irgendwas macht. Also das ist alles nicht so einfach. Vielleicht brauchen wir Selbsthilfe. Wer kennt Mel Robbins? Wir haben sie im letzten Podcast mal kurz gehört.
So wenig? Moment.
Nur wenige. Wir werden gleich sehen, das Phänomen ist riesengroß. Also manerweise müssen alle Hände hochgehen.
Nennst du gleich die Zahlen?
Ich nenne gleich die erschreckenden Zahlen. Aber wir kommen, wir nähern uns dem langsam an. Das ist Mel Robbins.
I have something so freaking cool to talk to you about today. I'm so glad that you showed up and that you're here with me. Oh my God. I've been using this thing that we're gonna talk about in my own life for a while now. And my kids call it the let them theory.
Die let them theory.
Hat davon jemand gehört.
Warum bringe ich die mit? Weil sie seit jetzt, glaub ich, schon 20 Wochen auf Platz eins ist, der beste Listen in Deutschland, Weltweit ein Riesenerfolg. Wir hören gleich noch was zu den Erfolgen ihres Podcasts. Sie hat also einen mega Bestseller verfasst. Alle kaufen dieses Buch. Und wir hören jetzt den Podcast, in dem sie zum ersten Mal diese Theorie entrollt. Sie hatte einen Post bei Social Media gemacht, der ist so gut angekommen, dass sie dachte, ich mach da ein Podcast. Wir sind jetzt im Jahr 2023, hangeln uns aber dann auch nach vorne vor und wollen jetzt erstmal wissen, was ist die Let-Them-Theorie. Und fragen uns vielleicht auch gleichzeitig, ist das eine Theorie?
The second I explain it to you, you're gonna get it completely. Because it is the simplest, most liberating mindset flip that you could ever know and you're just gonna love it. Can you tell how excited I am?
Ja, wir sind auch schon ganz aufgeregt, das Mindset wird jetzt gleich geändert.
Geflippt. Mindset flip. Nehme ich sofort in meinen Wortschatz auf.
Ja, ich habe ein bisschen Angst gehabt, das Thema mitzubringen, weil ich irgendwie Angst habe, dass du begeistert von diesem Wahnsinn bist.
Wolfgang lebt ja ohne Kinder, glaube ich. Ja.
Hypotheise.
Ich lebe ja mit Kindern. Bei Kindern, bevor der erste Hahn kräht, ist ja die Frage, Socken schon angezogen, Toastbrot schon gegessen, Dings schon gemacht, bla bla bla bla. Und hier ist ganz wichtig, Alfred Adlers Aufgabenteilung. Muss ich denn dem Kind die Socken anziehen? Muss ich dafür sorgen, dass es in der Schule keinen Hunger hat? Und so weiter und so fort. Von daher war für mich die Aufgabenteilung ist ein langes Wort. Let them theory ist schon, also let them ist noch ein kürzerer Gedanke. Also das muss noch mal rein kleiner machen.
Ja, ja. Ich will gleich sagen, so etwas funktioniert natürlich nur, wenn das Körnchen Wahrheit enthalten ist. Das heißt, wer sich jetzt von diesen 700 Beispielen, die sie nennt und ich habe wirklich nur 500 davon mitgebracht, und eigentlich gibt es 80.000, und die verbreitet sie in all ihren Podcasts und ihren Auftritten und ihren tollen Reden. Also natürlich werden wir alle da wiedererkennen und sagen, ja genau, sollte man so machen. Das Problem ist nur, wenn man wirklich eine Theorie draus bastelt. Aber erstmal müssen wir uns auch mal bedanken, bei denen, die jetzt neu dazugekommen sind, sagt Mel, die jetzt alle auch wissen wollen, was damit aufsieht.
But one more thing, before we jump in, I just wanted to take a minute and say, welcome to all of our new listeners. Welcome to the party that is the Mel Robbins Podcast. We've been waiting for you because this is the best group of people. So positive, so supportive. We want the best for you.
So positive.
Okay, wir gehen jetzt richtig rein.
In fact, I can give you the perfect example of how I use this thing from just this past weekend. See, it was our son, Oakley's prom. He's a junior in high school, and we went over to this person's house for pre-prom photos. And it starts to rain.
Es regnet also. Der Sohn hat da seinen wichtigen Anlass. Es regnet, die sind alle im Haus. Die ganzen Absolventen. Es ist nicht irgendein Regen. Es wird richtig dramatisch.
And not just rain. It is like a torrential downpour. The kind of storm where you go, that really sucks.
Ja, und diese Kinder nun aber haben so verrückte Ideen.
And so they're standing there, and it's about five o'clock at night, prom starts at seven, and the kids start talking. So what do you want to do for dinner? And I look at Oakley and I say, you guys don't have a reservation somewhere? He goes, no. And I then said, well, what are you going to do? Do you want me to call? And I start then jumping in, right? And over-functioning with my anxiety, which we have talked about before on this podcast. And the kids are kind of gathering around and somebody goes, well, why don't we go to Avocado Pit? Now Avocado Pit, just to put this in context, is this little amazing taco place, right? It's got maybe six stables in it.
Kleine Lokalität, da passen ja gar nicht alle rein. Und damit wir das auch wirklich verstehen, erklärt sie uns nochmal diese verfahrene Situation.
It's tiny. It's the size of one stall of a garage. So we're talking one car parking place. And there are 20 kids in tuxedos and long dresses, dressed to the nines. It is a torrential downpour outside. And their plans for prom are to go to a fast casual joint in the center of town that could maybe have six of them standing inside. And I immediately start going, you can't go to Avocado Pit. You're gonna get, what about, ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba. I am controlling. I'm that person. And my daughter turns to me and she says, Mom, if they want to go to Avocado Pit, let them. It's his problem. It's not your problem. Let them.
Das ist die Theorie. Lass sie doch machen. Das ist die Theorie. Und jetzt denkt man sich, gut, ja, haben wir selbst schon mal erfahren, manchmal hilft es, wenn man sich raushält. Aber wir haben alle kein Buch geschrieben. Sind alle nicht durch die Gegend getingelt, haben Vorträge für 50.000 Euro am Abend gehalten? Bei ihr ist es anders. Eine Theorie ward geboren.
And when she said, let them, it's as if I just went hands off. It was this little cue that was like, okay, you're doing that thing. Just turn from controlling everything now and let the current of what's happening take you in a different direction. And immediately what happens when you adopt the let them theory is that you are able to catch yourself when you're controlling people and you don't need to be. You are able to drop into a more surrender, peaceful feeling instead of letting your emotions rev you up. I use this thing in so many situations in my life, I've basically lost count at this point. But I'm going to give you a few examples.
Also, Wolfgang, du bist ja großer Fan von Sigmund Freud. Der hat ja zeitgleich mit Alfred Adler in Wien in den Kaffee-Stuben gesessen und hat dann einfach mit seinen Studenten geredet. Alfred Adler, für seinen Teil ist er nach Hause gegangen, hat einfach so Mitschriften des heute wieder Erkenntnisses blablabla. Und am Ende des Lebens waren das 3000 Seiten, und wir nennen es Individualpsychologie, große Theorie, wie auch immer und so weiter. So ist das bei Freud auch. Es sind halt kleine Gedanken, die dann einfach so lange aufgeschrieben werden.
Nein, nein, nein, nein. Also das geht nicht. Doch, doch, doch. Es ist wirklich bei Freud eine Theorie. Und bei Adler wegen mir auch und wegen mir auch noch, CG. Jung, aber hier das ist wirklich keine Theorie. Also wenn ich sage, ja, dann lass die anderen das machen, ich habe keine Lust oder zieh mich raus, dann kann das eine Art sein, wie man mit Situationen umgeht, aber umgeht, aber dass daraus jetzt eine Theorie gestrickt wird, bekommt dann irgendwann eine ideologische Komponente, die über dieses rein pragmatische hinausgeht. Oder sehr mal anders gesagt, ich könnte ja jetzt auch ein Buch schreiben, 300 Seiten darüber, dass es ratsam ist, dass man, wenn man sich die Schuhe angezogen hat, um das Haus zu verlassen, sie auch binden sollte.
Ja.
Das wissen die meisten Leute, manchmal muss man es noch mal Leuten hinterher rufen, denkt an die Schuhe zu binden, aber eine Theorie erwächst daraus ja nicht gleich. Also, wenn man sich dann diesen Podcast aber anhört weiter, dann verspricht sie immer, dass sie jetzt dann nochmal ganz tief reingeht. Aber eigentlich ist es nur ein additives Aneinanderrein, zum Beispiel hier.
So whenever I start to feel left out, or my feelings are hurt, I definitely tap the let them theory. For example, have you ever been in a situation where a bunch of your friends go away for the weekend and you're not included? Oh, kind of stings, right? Or maybe your golfing buddies take a trip and you're not invited? You can tell yourself, well, there's only four and I would be five or there's six couples and, you know, but I know it hurts. That's why you need the let them theory. Let them. If they're going on a golfing trip for four, let them. If a bunch of couples are going away, let them.
Oder ein ganz anderes Beispiel.
So your sister-in-law, for example, let's say she wants to host Thanksgiving this year, but you always host Thanksgiving. Let them.
Stefan will noch was trinken gehen. Wolfgang will nicht. Glättern.
Ja. Also. Also alles gemeinsam auszuräumen, sich komplett zurückzunehmen. Ist doch.
Ja, ist eine sehr interessante Idee von Gesellschaft.
Sie spiegelt das ja mit der let me-Komponente dieser Theorie noch.
Ja, ja. Sie will nämlich dadurch, kann sie sich natürlich auch selbst empauern, weil sie ja dann losgelöst ist von anderen. Also die müssen natürlich dann auch die Let Them Theorie wiederum anwenden. Und dann kann jeder so in sich selbst wachsen. Das ist die Idee. Und ja, es hilft manchmal, andere ziehen zu lassen, damit man seine Sachen machen kann. Ich lese ja zum Beispiel, das ist ja eine sehr solistische Tätigkeit. Da ist schon gut, wenn dann niemand stört dabei. Aber ich würde jetzt nicht gar ein Gesellschaftsprinzip draus machen. Vor allem auch die Anwendungen scheinen mir doch ein bisschen wahllos, beziehungsweise sollte man nicht an manchen Punkten mal intervenieren. Gut, also beim Verkehr ist es so, dass man jetzt nicht hinten den Rambock spielen kann. Aber ich sag mal, wenn es Entlassungen im Unternehmen gibt, gibt es ja vielleicht noch Betriebsrat, gibt es Gewerkschaften und so. Wir sehen schon, also die Gesellschaft an sich wird hier rausgedrängt. Die Gesellschaft let them und ich, ich, ich mache irgendwas anderes. Und jetzt könnte man ja, wie wir meinen, reicht das jetzt mal.
I could probably stop our conversation right here, right? Because I know you get it. But here's the thing about the let them theory that I've discovered having used this thing for a while. Just getting it at the surface is easy, but we've only just begun scratching the surface.
Wir haben erst an der Uhrfläche gekratzt. Ja. Jetzt wird's ziemlich ganz tief.
And 99% of the time, when you feel yourself trying to control a situation or another human being, I want you to use the let them theory. I want you to literally say to yourself, my mom and dad don't want to come to Thanksgiving, let them. My husband doesn't want to train for this triathlon that I've signed up for, let them. My roommates don't want to do dry January with me, let them.
Wir merken, es gewinnt jetzt in Normandtiefe. Ich finde es ganz gut, dass die drei Beispiel noch gekommen sind, sonst hätte ich nämlich die ersten nicht verstanden. Jetzt geht es dahin, dass sie dann doch sagt, es muss Ausnahmen geben. Das hat mich dann doch beruhigt.
If somebody is doing something dangerous, or they are discriminating against you, do not let them do that. So for example, if you've got a buddy or a family member that's had a couple drinks, don't let them get behind the wheel of a car. That's not a time to drop the oars and just go with the flow. If you see someone harassing someone or discriminating against someone, speak up.
Also immerhin, Es ist auch so ein minimal gesellschaftlicher Verantwortung, bleibt bestehen. Und meine Frage ist immer, warum sind, ich mein, das ist ja nur ein Phänomen, ein besonders erfolgreiches von sehr vielen. Warum sind Podcasts und andere Formate und Bücher so beliebt in den Menschen, die grundlegendsten Dinge erklärt bekommen, über die man ja noch nicht mal sich mit Worten mehr im Klaren werden muss, weil es ja selbstverständlich ist, dass man nicht sagt, wenn da jemand in einer Gefahrsituation steht oder drei Leute stehen auf dem Dach, das bald einbrechen kann, Let Them oder so, würde man ja nicht tun. Warum muss es noch mal gesagt werden? Fangen wir jetzt gerade noch mal an, die ganz rudimentären Grundlagen uns zu erarbeiten?
Wir haben ja eben über diesen Hegemann gesprochen, wir haben über Jens Jessen, Kumkau und so weiter, das mimetische Begehren, also alles wird immer über Bande gespielt. Überall ist immer zweite Beobachterebene. Und das bedeutet, man muss so ein bisschen mitdenken. Hier haben wir es mit so einem unmittelbaren, Ihre zweite Theorie, falls du die später noch ansprichst.
Wir kommen noch, wir wollen schon das gesamte Opus.
Okay, also die zweite Theorie, und da werken wir dann, es darf einfach Zeit keine Rolle spielen, es muss so schnell gehen, ja? Und man ist auf so einer unmittelbaren Ebene, und das finde ich auch super, weil hier könnte man ja sofort dramatisieren, die, sagen wir mal, Weihnachtsfeier, drei Generationen, die mittlere Generation möchte sich gerne ins Aufräumen einmischen. Und die jüngste Generation sagt aber nein, das ist mein Haushalt, Mama, du bist hier nicht zu Hause. Und so. Und dann steht jemand daneben aus der dritten Generation lebensweise und sagt zu beiden, let them. Und dann ist es ja perfekt. Dann ist der L'Oréal.
Ja, ja. Es gibt doch eine Ausnahme, immerhin.
Always negotiate your salary. Do not just let the first offer be what you accept.
Guck mal, wie hochkompatibel diese Theorie ist. Alles passt da rein.
Find ich das schon ganz gut, dass die Edmelin-Sagler-Lohnverhandlungen nicht einfach das Angebot annehmen. Jetzt wirkt die Theorie aber bei folgendem Beispiel wieder.
Here's another comment. A friend told me that she was so upset and disappointed that another friend had gone without her on a trip that she thought that they were supposed to take together. My god was she fixated on it. She just couldn't let it go. This is the perfect opportunity to tell your friend about the let them theory. If you heard about the let them theory, for all you know, it's not that they didn't want to go with you, it's that they just needed time alone. So let them take the trip alone.
Siehst du, so was weiß sie dann noch alles.
Jaja, also wir enthalten das gar nicht.
Die wollten halt nur Zeit alleine verbringen.
Wer weiß, vielleicht ist aber auch genau anders. Vielleicht mögen die einen wirklich nicht mehr und man macht sich ernsthaft Gedanken, das hat man vielleicht falsch gemacht. Könnte man natürlich auch mal so betrachten. Nun ist es so, dass ich schon sage, diese Theorie entsteht ja nicht aus dem Nichts. Also wir sehen, wie eigentlich alles, auf das Ich zuläuft und das Ich soll es selbst machen. Ja, Horst und Topf rufen uns zu, liest jeden Tag eine Seite in unserem Buch, räumen dann Zimmer auf, sagt Jordan Peterson und dann machen bisschen Krypto und dann wirst du Millionär werden. Du, du allein wirst es schaffen, wenn du es denn nur willst. Und in gewisser Weise ist es auch eine Theorie der Entsolidarisierung mit dem Let Them, wenngleich ich natürlich zugestehe, auf pragmatischer Ebene kann das helfen. Und ja, wir alle kennen Leute oder sind vielleicht Leute, die sich zu sehr ständig in irgendwas einmischen, wo man sagen muss, gut, dann lass sie es so machen. Also ich bin immer der, der sich pragmatisch auch rauszieht aus Dingen. Ich komme später hinzu, bringe eine Flasche mit oder so, die ich dann öffnen kann. Aber wir hören mal, was sie da eigentlich noch weiter will.
This can be a little trickier. Because this is when you really need to take a step back and you gotta let people fail. And you've gotta give people the room to grow, the room to learn, and the room to take personal responsibility for something in their life. And I'm gonna give you a couple examples of this.
Zum Beispiel, wenn da das Kind ein Vorstellungsgespräch hat, oder sonst die Schwester ein Vorstellungsgespräch hat.
If they forget an application deadline for a job, let them forget. Why? Because they needed to learn that lesson.
Also, so ein bisschen...
Also, dieses Buch war sehr erfolgreich. Es gibt sogar Unterbücher zum Thema, falls ihr darüber redet, hier eine kleine Handreichung, wie auch immer. Es gibt Let them theory für Parenting. Und da muss ich ehrlich sagen, der letzte Tipp hier, der war nicht schlecht. Wenn das Kind sich die Schuhe nicht anzieht, es geht halt trotzdem in die Schule. Es stellt dann schon fest, Schuhe werden besser, wie auch immer. Also man muss nicht immer zu sehr hinterher sein und so weiter. Ich habe diese Erfahrung gemacht, als ich meinen Sohn mal im Kindergarten abgeholt hab damals. Wenn ich gesehen habe, also ein bisschen früher als sonst abgeholt. Okay, also wenn die aufwachen nach Mittagsschlaf, dann hat jeder im Flur so ein Handtuch und auf das setzt er sich einfach drauf. Und daneben liegen die Sachen und dann wird man erst mal wach. Also dieses wie zu Hause, ah du bist wach, schön, ja genau, weil ich habe dich ja geweckt und in drei Minuten bist du angezogen, warte ich ziehe dich an. Das dauert da zehnmal so lange und die machen das alles selbst. Und da habe ich mir so gedacht, das kann ich auch zu Hause machen. Also im Sinne von, das ist eine wirklich gute Idee, ich gebe ihm zehn Minuten mehr Zeit, formuliere klar die Aufgabe und dann lasse ich ihn.
Okay, wir sind jetzt ja im Bereich Kinder. Und die gehen Erwachsene mit ihnen um. Jetzt Untergeschwistern.
Ist das Wichtigste.
Ja, ja, ja, Untergeschwistern.
Every time that you bail your sister out, who's terrible with money, and you loan her money, you know what happens? She continues to be terrible with money. Sometimes you need the sting of 11-bounce checks or the lien on the house.
Also, wer Geldprobleme hat, der soll keine Hilfe erhalten. Muss man selbst machen.
And when you constantly rescue people, you're teaching them that they're not capable of rescuing themselves.
Das stimmt.
Nee, das stimmt in gewisser Weise. Also, das ist ja genau diese Sache. Ja, es gibt natürlich Leute, die chronisch immer wieder in irgendwas reingeraten und sich dann nicht am Riemen reißen. So und dann kann man auch in den Worten darüber reden. Und dann kann man auch denen sagen, jetzt kriegt man den Arsch hoch. Das Problem ist ja nur, dass das ja sowieso jeder weiß. Also das muss ich mir nicht nochmal von jemandem erzählen lassen, Ultimillionen schwer.
Wolfgang, dass das jeder weiß.
Wer das nicht weiß, der weiß das auch durch das Buch nicht. Die Sache ist nur hier, dass das Ausdruck ist einer Gesellschaft, die eigentlich sagt, naja, die Menschen müssen sich schon selbst retten. Brauche ich denn überhaupt einen Sozialstaat, weil die sich doch eigentlich gut selbst retten müssten? Und wenn sie das so formuliert und sagt...
Every time you rescue somebody, you rob them of the opportunity to grow. Every time you step in and you make the problem go away, you make the person a little weaker.
Das würde Christian Lindner auch sagen. In Bezug auf, müssen wir Bürgergeld erhöhen? Brauchen wir eine besondere Unterstützung für die Familien? Müssen wir sehen, dass die Studenten, die BAföG-Schulden haben, davon entlastet werden? Nein, das sind natürlich dornige Chancen. Und an denen wächst man. Wenn man denen das wegnimmt. So, und das ist genau das Problem bei dieser Theorie, in dem sie die ganze Zeit unpolitisch bleibt. Aber dass in einem ganz größeren Diskurs geht, wo es ja nicht darum nur geht, ob die Kinder jetzt die Schuhe anziehen oder in Sandalen rausgehen, bekommt es natürlich eine andere Dimension. Und ist natürlich auch deshalb gerade verfängt das so gut, weil sowieso sich niemand mehr auf den Sozialstaat oder so verlässt.
Also wir sind hier in dem, das kennen wir nicht, erfolgreichen Genre-Buchmarkt. Und da geht es ganz selten um Politik. Da geht es um den Darm.
Aber das ist politisch.
Naja, also.
Dass so eine Theorie kommt, die so sehr auf das Individuum abzieht, wir werden ja gleich noch die anderen Beispiele hören. Sehen wir ja, dass das nur in einer so radikalisierten, individualisierten Gesellschaft passieren kann.
Also in meiner Idealwelt ist ja gerade nicht alles politisch, sondern es reicht, wenn überhaupt einmal am Tag die Tagesschau zu sehen. Da ist also sehr viel Raum für nicht Politisches, wo trotzdem Sachen geregelt werden müssen. Also nicht jede Lösung für alltägliche Sorgen sind politischer Natur. Und wenn man jetzt gut will, das Thema Geld, beispielsweise kommen wir schon häufig in politische Sphären hier rein. Genau, aber wenn wir an das Metier jetzt herangehen, indem wir sagen, dieses Buch steht im Regal neben Damen mit Charme, dann irgendwas zur Ernährung nochmal, dann was zum Thema Haut, Haare und dann die Let Them Theory, da wo sie hingehört, da liest man das natürlich anders. Und da ist auch ein bisschen mehr Wahres dran als jetzt.
Da bin ich mir eben nicht so sicher, weil diese Leute wählen ja zum Beispiel auch und haben zum Beispiel dann, also man fragt sich ja, ohne dass das sehr politische Leute sind, fragt man sich ja, wie kann das sein, dass es so einen Hass auf Bürgergeldempfänger gibt, von Leuten, die überhaupt nicht genau wissen, wie hoch die Sätze sind für Bürgergeld, die keine Bürgergeldempfänger kennen und und und. Das liegt schon daran, dass sie alle immer inkorporiert haben. Scheitern kann eine Chance sein. Ich muss es selbst schaffen.
Mir hat auch keiner geholfen. Also, warum sollte ich denen, was von meinem sauer erarbeiteten Geld abgeben? Die sitzen ja eh nur da. Steh mal morgens auf. Let them und so weiter. Und ich glaube, dass diese Konstellation absolut da ist. Und ja auch dann zeigt, warum das ein so großes Phänomen ist. Weil das muss ja mit einer Ideologie auch sein. Weil ja, die Leute jetzt nicht sagen, es kann ja niemand diesen Rat ernst nehmen, weil den wusste ja schon jeder vorher.
Ja, aber ich würde sagen, das Pendel hier nicht komplett überschlagen lassen.
Wir gehen mal weiter. Erstmal verabschieden wir uns aus der ersten Episode zu diesem Thema.
I can't wait to hear how you use the let them theory. You know what my dog's barking? You know what I'm gonna do? I'm just gonna let the dogs bark.
Ja, ich hoffe, dass der Hund auf den Teppich pinkelt. Wir erleben jetzt ganz kurz Mel Romans bei wem wohl der schrecklichsten Person Amerikas, Oprah Winfrey.
Let them is when you release control. Oh my goodness, it's so freeing. Because you know the truth. Bing, bing, bing, bing, bing.
Also ich mein, da muss man ja wirklich so sehen wir ja deren geworden... .matsch sein, wenn man so redet. Aber ich mein, das haben ja Leute wie Eva Illes und so wirklich gut analysiert. Diese Oprah Winfrey Ideologie, die haben ja wirklich gezeigt, wie die mit dem Neoliberalismus passgenau ist. Natürlich darf auch der andere nicht fehlen. Wir hatten ihn schon mal, als er Joe Biden im Interview hatte, Jay Shetty auch ganz angetan.
Powerful is this idea of let them also show you who they are. Yes. And if they're showing you who they are, let them be that person. Don't make them the person you imagine them to be, the one you want them to be, the one that you're wishing and waiting and hoping for them to be. They are that person. Oh my gosh, my mind is literally blown because that is so powerful.
Ja.
Also, lasst uns jetzt in Ruhe oder will du uns weiter runter callen und...
Na, es ist völlig das Mäuschen. Also, dass man andere Menschen als Menschen auch mal so sein lässt, das ist auch ganz neue Erkenntnis. Dann gibt's The Nerve. Das ist, weiß nicht, wer das so ist, bei YouTube jedenfalls. Die hat das kritisiert. Dieses Buch erzählt dann mal über die Ticketpreise. Ist ein bisschen teurer als die Kells.
Ich bin in Tours right now, by the way. She's hitting New York City in a few weeks. I might go. The lowest ticket, 500. Biggest ticket, $1,500. If I'm paying $1,500 to see somebody speak, it better be Jesus Christ himself coming down from heaven. Okay, here we go. Mel Robbins, The Witten Wisdom. The fact is, every human being is dealt a different hand in life. You don't say. Secondly, it's not about the hand you've been dealt. Let them.
Da geht's nämlich dann schon um das gesellschaftliche. Dann sag mal einfach, die einen sind in der Hartz-IV-Familie geboren, die anderen sind Söhne einer Rehdersfamilie. Die haben wohl die besseren Karten. Let them. Und dann ist gut. Also, braucht man keine Vermögenssteuer oder irgendwas mehr einführen. Jetzt ist es natürlich so eine Theorie, bei denen manchen sagen, kann ich mir das behalten eigentlich, was mir Robbins so vorschlägt? Denn es ist ja, ja, es sind ja immerhin auch zwei Worte hintereinander. Es gibt da einen kleinen Trick, nämlich diesen hier.
A let them tattoo is a powerful reminder to embrace detachment, acceptance and self growth. The phrase let them comes from the idea that we cannot control others, we can only control ourselves. It encourages people to let go of expectations, stop chasing validation and allow things to unfold naturally. This tattoo resonates with those who have experienced heartbreak, betrayal.
Ja, schon.
Also das verstehe ich aber wirklich nicht. Wenn man sich das selber tätowiert, gerade hier an die Hand, will man doch den Let Me Teil da stehen haben. Zum Sinn von Sprich zur Hand.
Oder man hat zwei, vielleicht so und so.
Dann kann man gleich machen. Wie kann man? Also das verstehe ich nicht.
Ja. Mel Robbins erzählt mal von ihrem Erfolg in einem anderen Podcast.
And every single day that you talk yourself out of beginning or taking one step forward is a day that you're keeping yourself locked in a prison of your own making. Because if you know something that you want, how dare you withhold it from yourself? How dare you talk yourself out of it? How dare you sit there and spend more time and energy manufacturing excuses and worrying about what other people think? You get one life. And no one is coming to save you. No one is coming to do the work for you. Nobody is going to pick you from obscurity and make you a star. Nobody is going to build the business that you want to build.
Niemand wird da sein, also du bist es immer nur allein. Das hat natürlich in einem so unternehmerisch gedachten Wege in gewisser Weise einen Sinn, wenngleich sie natürlich auf sehr viel zurückgreift, das einfach schon vorhanden ist. Sie befindet sich ja innerhalb einer Gesellschaft und nutzt ja eine Infrastruktur. Aber indem sie das so verabsolutiert, versucht sie ja jetzt hier eigentlich allen klar zu machen, na ja, es liegt also an dir, wenn du es nicht schaffst, sie her. Ich habe es ja geschafft. Und jetzt haben wir die Let-Them-Theory kennengelernt. Aber ich habe dann herausgefunden, Mel Robbins hat noch eine weitere Theorie. Und das ist die Fünf-Sekunden-Regel. Wir nähern uns auch diese.
Warte, wer kennt die Fünf-Sekunden-Regel? Dachtet ihr, das ist natürlich eine andere.
Ah, so ist das ein Sticken mit H.
My secret to success is very simple. I get out of fucking bed when I don't feel like it. End of story.
Also, man zählt einen Countdown, fünf Sekunden. Und dann muss man aufstehen. Und das ist die Fünf Sekundenregel. Fünf Sekunden. Also einfach immer, wenn man was eigentlich machen muss, und noch so fünf Sekunden, und dann muss man los.
And I truly believe that you're one decision away from a completely different life. That doesn't mean you achieve the success that you want with one decision. It means that with one decision, and for me that decision was getting out of bed when I didn't feel like it. Getting out of bed when I was $800,000 in debt.
Also sie hat 800.000 Dollar Schulden. Und der Weg war, ich geh eben mal lieber aus dem Bett raus. Ja, ich war ja vor der Schuldung, ist ja ein großes Problem in Deutschland. Ich hatte auch mal gedacht, das hatte auch so soziale Faktoren und so, aber offenbar wissen die nur noch nicht um diese 5 Sekundenregel. Jetzt kann man sagen, gut, warum arbeiten wir uns so sehr daran ab? Wie erfolgreich ist denn Mel Robbins wirklich? Wir hören es uns an. Sie sagt es uns nämlich selbst dann in einem späteren Podcast.
And so I wanted to start the episode today by sharing some extraordinary news with you. You ready? I found out about an hour ago, that the Mel Robbins Podcast is the fifth most followed podcast of 2023 on Apple globally. Number five. I have literally, I mean, first of all, that's my number, the five second rule, the high five habit.
Aber da stimmt ihr bei ein. Sie ist überrascht, du bist überrascht.
Ja. Ja, und es geht noch weiter mit dem Erfolg.
Number freaking five in the world. And you know what? That's not all. One of our episodes was named the number six most shared episode in the world of all of 2023 on both Spotify and Apple. And I could not wait to tell you. And I want to put this in perspective, Both for me and for you, because this is insane.
Ja, würde ich zustimmen wollen, ist wirklich verrückt.
Vielleicht sollten wir unser Geschäftsmodell für diesen Podcast auch nochmal überdenken. Der Horst und Hopf ist ja auch sehr erfolgreich mit Wassertrinken. Da kommt man ja auch nicht voll alleine drauf. Vielleicht sollten wir wirklich noch einen Schuh-Anzieh-Podcast machen.
Aber was sagt uns das eigentlich über die Gesellschaft, wenn wir jetzt immer solche Tipps bekommen, die wir schon wussten? Also Wassertrinken ist ja auch ein super Beispiel, wenn man immer sagt, ja, kann helfen. Und ja, es hilft tatsächlich auch, ich kenne das, weil ich viel unterwegs bin, wenn man pünktlich aus dem Bett aufsteht, weil man dann den Zug erreicht.
Naja, du musst natürlich diesen kleinen Kniff finden, die Überraschung im super allgemein verständlichen, also Wassertrinken, aber nicht aus dem Wasserhahn. Morgens einen Plan für den Tag haben, aber ihn auch wirklich in Angriff nehmen.
Nämlich mit der Fünf-Sekunden-Rege.
Ich glaube, da fallen uns noch 100.000 Sachen ein.
Ja, und pass auf, wir sind jetzt fast am Ende noch zwei Clips und die Aufmerksamen unter uns haben schon mitbekommen, Sie hat da doch noch irgendwas erwähnt. Da gibt es noch irgendwas mit einer 5. Ja, es gibt noch eine kleine Theorie von Mel Robbins. Die High Five Theorie oder das High Five Konzept. Kennt das auch jemand? Das ist noch nicht so bekannt und wollen wir es hier ein bisschen populär machen. Also erst mal das Szenario. Kennen wir alle. Im Badezimmer, morgens.
There are always two of you in the bathroom together. There's you and there is a human being in the mirror, a person who needs you, a person who has been waiting for you to wake up and realize they are there and they need you to see them and to hear them and to love them and to support them. You're basically just gonna look at yourself in the mirror and you're gonna ask yourself, what does that human being need for me today? How can I show up for him or her or they? How do I do that today? Kindness, do I need to be more courageous or bold? You kind of set this intention. For yourself.
Mhm.
Also im Sinne des Shijekchen ist es die Dummheit.
Wahrscheinlich. Ja, würde man wohl so sagen.
Alles dreht sich um dich.
Ja. Also als hätte man es nicht auch vorher gewusst. Also ich finde immer so interessant, dass Leute nochmal gesagt werden bekommen, dass man so selbst... Also ich habe nicht den Eindruck, dass die Leute alle so selbst vergessen, wo sie nicht sind. Also ich bin es zum Beispiel nicht. Also ich habe nicht vergessen. Ich sehe es nicht so häufig. Aber ich werde es natürlich morgen gleich mal ausprobieren. Denn es ist ja nicht nur, dass ich im Spiegel mit mir spreche, sondern jetzt kommt es ja. Jetzt kommt wirklich der Move, der gemacht werden muss.
Every morning after brushing your teeth, we're going to stack this habit. Put the toothbrush down, pick up your hand, look yourself in the mirror and say, How am I going to show up for that human being today and seal it with a high five? That's it. Your mood in the morning impacts your confidence and your productivity all day.
High five. Das ist der Weg. Also, wir sehen, man kann heute sehr viel Erfolg haben, wenn man aus einem halben Gedanken ein ganzes Buch formuliert und 70 Podcastfolgen dazu aufnimmt. Sie ist momentan die erfolgreichste Speakerin überhaupt in diesem Lebenshilfebereich.
Jetzt hast du die Zahl gar nicht genannt. Also sechs Millionen Verkäufe in 62 Sprachen.
Ja.
Die Welt hatte Bedarf.
Ja. Das heißt für uns, wir sagen an dieser Stelle Let Them. Wir sagen aber auch high five zu allen, die da sind. Und zählen runter. 5, 4, 3, 2, 1. Vielen Dank. Bis zum nächsten Mal. Tschüss.